bon on est là
mais mais sans sans les jouur pas qu
vous dire en fait on sait pas quoi vous
dire mais c'est pas on attend 18h5 on a
ah oui à digitar 5 c'est le meilleur
moment de notre journée on va parler à
quelqu'un qui travaille chez Meetup on
est vraiment très heureux avec Fab mais
premier degré donc Marie lou bon
j'espère que ça va bien se passer mais
là c'est c'est notre c'est notre moment
bonheur du stream on aurait préféré que
ça ait lieu pendant les parties donc
esppère ça va vite vite démarrer mais
bon sin ouais non je crois pas mais
sinon je coupe le live he je parle à
Marie loup et puis je enfin tant pis
peut-être je sais pas si tu un autre
habillage que tout
ronde je vois en haut à gauche tu vois
ouais ou pas enfin c'est premier à 4 et
demi en plus
i tout tout a changé
là je sais pas où
c'est
euh ouais donc bon ben aujourd'hui un
peu comme vous le savez on on va
assister au demi-finale et demain aussi
d'ailleurs
euh demi-finale avec donc les matchs
entre so et abdous satorov wesle sa qui
a eu l'honneur de terminer premier a pu
choisir son adversaire il a choisi de
jouer contre le jeune abdous satorov
pourtant très dangereux et il a laissé à
à Magnus Carl ça tu penses Abd satorov
c'est quelqu'un c'est
qui c'est quelqu'un j'ai que saut mais
c'est peut-être juste un
arbitre donc ça c'est le match qui nous
intéresse pas
ah voilà le match qui nous intéresse les
joueurs arrivent donc voilà so euh so
qui très en forme euh contre NBE
abdorof et bien sûr peut-être sentant il
rajeter un œil à l'autre match mais on a
pensé quand même West lesau vainqueur de
du tout rond B c'est un match qu'on voit
moins souvent c'est plus intéressant
enfin moi ça m'intéresse plus en fait
toi aussi on a discuté on était tous les
deux d'accord euh mais bon là on va
vooir le moment euh clé not plaisir not
plaisir avec Marilou c'est bien on va
pourir un peu arrêter de parler d'échec
parler un peu d'autres
chosesre respiration quoi on va parler
Meetup on va parler
Meetup ça aurait été que moi ça aait été
on a on aurait eu les display j'ur avoir
les display en plus j'ai déjà bossé avec
eux sur ma chaîne et tout ils sont sont
hyper cool les Meetup on va appeler
Marilou 18h5 je dis 18h5 je t'appelle on
appelle Mar c'est parti on va j'espère
que ça a bien
marché allô Marilou
oui bonjour salut Marilou tu nous
entends oui je vous entends très bien ah
super super on est super content de te
parler Marilou on est on est donc en
direct on est en direct alors nous de
France mais en fait en direct de Toronto
en quelque sorte avec le tournoi et on a
maril lou Marilou qui représente Meetup
oui exactement bonjour ça me fait
plaisir d'être avec vous ouais c'est
c'est c'est super alors est-ce que tu
peux nous raconter nous avec Fabien là
on est donc en commentaire et et on
aimerait en savoir plus déjà qu'est-ce
que c'est Meetup oui absolument donc
Meetup est une plateforme qui permet aux
gens de se rencontrer de trouver des
événements et des groupes donc ça a en
fait été créé il y a plus de 20 ans à
New York mais c'est maintenant un
phénomène international on est dans plus
de 190 pays et et i c'est vraiment
fantastique donc dans les premières
années on était
principalement notre but était vraiment
de connecter les gens en présentiel mais
bon avec la pandémie les choses ont
changé et donc maintenant on offre
vraiment l'opportunité aux gens de
connecter de toutes les façons donc ce
soit en présentiel ou virtuellement ou
même récemment on a même l'option de se
rencontrer de façon hybride donc
vraiment notre but c'est notre but notre
mission c'est de connecter les gens et
dans le dans le monde des échecs donc de
permettre à à tous les gens qui veulent
qui veulent jouer aux échecs de débutant
à professionnel de se rencontrer à
travers à travers tout ça et donc si si
demain on voulait créer une rencontre là
j'en j'en sais rien je dis une bêtise
mais là je avec Fabien on est à Cann on
voudrait créer une
rencontre disons j'en sais rien moi en
mi-avril on pourrait on pourrait la
créer sur Meetup et et laisser les gens
s'y
inscrire exactement donc c'est bien ça
donc Chess.com en fait a euh une
communauté qui est déjà créée sur sur
meub alors c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
facile si vous êtes seulement quelqu'un
qui veut participer à un événement vous
pouvez euh joindre notre plateforme donc
c'est tout à fait gratuit pour
s'inscrire euh et puis vous une fois que
vous êtes inscrit sur Meetup euh vous
pouvez chercher pour un événement échec
vous pouvez aller directement sur la
page qui est spécifique pour Chess.com
et vous vous pouvez voir tous les
événements qui qui se passent près de
chez vous euh ou si même ça vous dit de
de devenir vous-même l'organisateur et
peut-être de de démarrer un groupe vous
pouvez le faire de façon gratuitement
également donc vraiment génial une belle
façon de de de rencontrer d'autres
adeptes des échecs ouais nous on serait
plutôt cô organisateur avec Fab mais
peut-être que dans le dans le chat des
gens qui nous suivent sont plutôt pour
pour rejoindre donc vous pouvez vous
pouvez le voir il y a déjà beaucoup de
de membres chesscom la communauté
chesscom elle est elle est active sur
Meetup
actuellement oui tout à fait donc assez
incroyable on a démarré le programme
l'année dernière et on a déjà 382
groupes à travers le monde et ça c'est à
travers 69 pays et je regardais nos les
stats eu et on vienent de on vient tout
juste d'atteindre les 30000 membres euh
donc un gros Milestone pour la
communauté et vraiment c'est vraiment
excitant de voir tellement de gens qui
qui rejoignent les les différents
groupes et qui se rencontent chaque
semaine et le le le chess boom tu tu il
a fait un il a il a eu un impact sur sur
la communauté chikienne Meetup tout tout
le Queens Gambit et tout ce qu'on a
connu là il y a 2 3 ans vous avez vu un
une une belle
augmentation absolument et je je
regardait justement dernièrement voir
l'évolution et la popularité sur me
c'est c'est c'est fou euh donc on a
actuellement à peu près en moyenne 1200
événements et spécifiquement pour les
échecs euh sur meup chaque mois et ça
c'est à peu près deux fois plus de ce
qu'on voyait en 2021 donc en 2 ans on a
vraiment doublé le le le la la volume
d'activité relié aux échecs donc on
ressent le le chess boom totalement sur
sur meup et euh c'est c'est quoi le
qu'est-ce qui pourrait permettre à à
Meetup et aux échecs d'évoluer ensemble
quelles sont les prochaines phases pour
pour faire pour faire encore progresser
parce que enfin moi personnement je
trouve que c'est génial d'avoir la
possibilité de dépasser le online et de
se rencontrer pour jou aux échecs c'est
quand même une fois que tu as beaucoup
jou en ligne tu as envie de de jouer en
présentiel et de rencontrer des gens
c'est les échecs c'est quelque chose qui
relie les gens donc quelles sont les
étapes pour pour encore le développer et
peut-être nous aussi s'il y a des gens
qui sont motivés pour pour faire quelque
chose notamment en France aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on comment ça peut évoluer
comment on peut aussi aider ces
communautés à à secré à fonctionner
oui oui tout à fait en fait Meetup et
Chess.com ont ont vraiment collaboré
dans les dernières deux années pour
faciliter cette connexion là donc oui tu
sais c'est facile de de jouer aux échecs
en ligne mais comme vous dites c'est
c'est tellement c'est tellement
enrichissant de rencontrer d'autres
personne d'avoir cette connexion là qui
se passe et en personne c'est c'est ce
qu'on dit pour nous Meetup la la magie
se passe quand les personnes se
rencontrent en vrai donc en personne euh
donc notre but c'est de trouver des
nouvelles façons de de vraiment
faciliter la collaboration donc on est
en train d'explorer des façons de de
rendre ça encore plus facile pour les
utilisateurs s'il sont s'ils sont sur
cheslecom qu'ils ont envie de connecter
avec d'autres gens et de leur montrer
les événements qui se passe déjà autour
d'eux et donc une recherche facile
peut-être d'événement près près de chez
soi euh donc on est en train d'explorer
les différentes façons de de connecter
nos deux plateformes pour euh vraiment
créer le pont entre le le désir des gens
de pratiquer les échecs de de devenir
meilleur mais de aussi former une
communauté puis de de se retrouver
ensemble là-dedans ouais c'est c'est
nous ce qu'on a remarqué hein que les
gens tu sais quand on discute sur
Internet qu'on voit les gens dans le
chat discuter et tout il y a quand même
cette envie souvent de de se rencontrer
c'est super qu'il y a un outil qui
permett de le faire au au sein au sein
des échecs est-ce que tu peux aussi nous
dire maintenant qu'on te connaît un
petit peu Mariloup est-ce que tu peux
nous dire toi comment comment ça s'est
passé comment tu es arrivé à Meetup
oui comment ça se passe de ton côté quoi
ben oui en fait moi je suis je suis
originaire de de de Montréal que vous
avez probablement entendu avec mon ACC
tu un mag tu as un magnifique
accent euh mon mon mon français
québécois donc oui en fait j'ai eu la
chance de la vie m'aemmener à New York
il y a 7 ans et je suis vraiment tombe
en amour avec avec la la mission meup
donc j'ai joint l'équipe et puis depuis
depuis que j'ai joint
mon mon rôle à meup et vraiment de
travailler avec différentes
organisations pour les aider à créer des
des programmes de communauté donc des
entreprises de toute taille ça peut être
un petit yoga studio qui veut qui veut
trouver plus de gens ou des des
grandes des grandes organisations comme
ch.com qui veulent vraiment
faire un impact positif et connecter les
gens et donc voilà c'est c'est mon
histoire donc ça va faire 7 ans 7 ans en
février que j'ai la chance de travailler
avec des gens incroyables chaque jour et
tu es
heureuse je suis très heureuse comment
ne pas être heureuse avec une mission si
belle de d'avoir le but de de connecter
les gens autour de nos intérêts puis de
de ce qui nous de ce qui nous passionne
je pense que c'est c'est vraiment
magnifique franchement ça c'est c'est
c'est un beau boulot et merci merci de
faire ça j'espère que ça sera utile
enfin nous ça nous va va nous être utile
et j'espère que ce sera utile aussi aux
gens qui nous écoutent et qui pourront
rencontrer d'autres personnes
intéressantes l'amitié peut-être l'amour
qui tout tout tout tout tout toutoup
tout tout est possible Marilou je je me
permets de tenter du Québécois les les
parties sont en train de jouer on a pas
le temps de niaiser j'espère que c'est
dans ce cas là qu'on le dit la seule
chose en québétois que je connais
j'espère que c'est bon Marilou c'est
très trè bien c'est un très bon usage
merci beaucoup beaucoup
pour merci encore merci encore Marilou
on te souhaite une super journée et et
on espère te dire nous déjà on te dit à
bientôt on espère plus globalement que
la communauté te dis à bientôt sur sur
Meetup pour de superp
événementsent on vous voit sur Meetup
merci à tout le monde merci ciao ciao
Marou merci
encore c'était maril Lou qui nous a
gratifié d'un super accent québécois
c'était hyper positif on est super
content est-ce qu'on regarde les parties
ou pas ouis on peut parler un peu de
Meetup ouais ouais je sais pas mais
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui sont sur
Meetup Mo j'ai envie de parler de
meetupainant My pont quoi mais du coup
oui c'est si tu veux juste faire une
soirée échec tiens dans un pub ou
quoi ah mais ça bon ça c'est encore plus
développé
[Musique]
mais est-ce que ça pourrait le faire euh
est-ce qu'on est à jour là sur la
position par rapport cam mais je je suis
dans le secret ouais je ouais en fait je
saisais pas je vois jouer des coups j'ai
l'impression qu'il faisait des échanges
genre comme si prendit ou quoi bon bah
pas du tout en fait moi je suis moi je
suis sur Meetup là j'ai quasiment envie
de me connecter à Meetup aller voir un
peu ce qui on crée un compte tant pis
pour les parties enfin et vas-y on crée
un truc ce so ah on pas sur la bonne
partie on est sur
carwana Oui e ben fait je envoyer
changer des pièces ouis mais bon c'est
pas grave on est en plein MEAP bon alors
voilà hein
euh al il y a eu des échanges voilà
cétait quoi je comprends que c'est
espagnol non toute façon on était en
Meetup à fond toute façon tant vous
répondez pas sur Meetup on ne parle pas
de la partie quoi si vous avez déjà un
compte et cetera si vous comptez
organiser des
[Musique]
événements ce truc en plus vraiment
c'est c'est un beau projet c'est
vraiment un beau projet c'est une sorte
de Facebook moderne quelque part ou plus
pro j bien parce que c'est pas mais ça
connecte les gens donc c'est cool
franchement c'est hyper positif people
j'ai créé un compte sur MEAP ouis bon
voilà
ok mvel ça dit quoi ah mvel c'est enfin
c'est c'est fini il est dans l'avion ou
pas mais c'est pour ça qu'on regarde
tranquille de toute façon il y a plus de
Français enfin oui oui bon on regarde là
il y a quatre parties première 2 et demi
c'est la première partie demain il y a
le match retour donc bon là fou on
s'échauffe quoi là j'aurais bien plus
parler du site essayer de naviguer qui
vous apprenne à faire des trucs dessus
enfin jeaurais plus par si sur un live
pour
faire et onement
etou et puis après sur un petit peu
peut-être tu vois pour la deuxième
partie faire un peu de
displate une partie un peu de Puma on
aura un peu regarder les pull les
machins bah ouais peut-être se faire
offrir un petit pull au passage quoi bah
ouais j' des Meetup de produit design
super uti et on trouve des superp event
aussi ouais tuis les gens sont très
heureux de MEAP bravo bravo me bravo
messieurs bravo MEAP un peu de secret là
on aurait parlé
siège on peut rappeler Mariloup hein
pour lui dire on a un peu discuté avec
le chat ouais en fait tester le site en
fait on arrête ouais bon beaucoup plus
intéressant pour le boulot la musique le
sport ça change la vie je ve trouver
l'amitié ou l'amour
enfin come ça pour le sport genre tu
veux jouer au tennis tu as pas de
partenaire tu fais un Meetup et tu joues
au tennis avec quelqu'un ou euh de
rencontrer des gens ouis faire des
marathon enfin est-ce que ça peut être
du du tête à tête quoi je veux dire ou
alors oui c'est plus un truc collectif
de
groupe en ce cas c'éit super euh c'était
super Fab
ouais non là il y a plus quatre joueurs
il y a plus de Français euh bon on a a
le seum on a le seum voilà on espère
avoir des belles
parties Abdat il peut il peut il donne
des belles Games souvent ouais ouais
c'est intéressant alors là bon c'est
assez symétrique on va voir sa de toute
façon dans son élément des positions pas
trop risqué s'il peut un peu travailler
son adversaire au corps euh ça lui plaît
quoi et on dit je crois qu'il 6 qualifi
sur 8 c'est ça alors il y en avait 6 sur
8 mais pas pour longtemps c'estàd en
fait le but c'est en demi-finale donc 6
tu fais pas des demi-final avec 6 FA
soit qure donc en fait fallait déjà être
dans les six pour pas être directement
dégagé ce qui a été le cas
malheureusement de d'za et de la zavic
euh mais après les 3 4 5 6 il devit
encore se battre pour pour être
demi-finaliste et malheureusement maxime
a échoué a échoué contre ikarou qui a
lui ensuite échoué contre aborof qui va
luichoué contre so voilà échoua contre
car tout monde échoue VO et puis puis
voilà en fait
euh donc
bref donc là maintenant nouveau format
attention he là c'est des matchs en
quatre parties et d'ailleurs c'est que
la première manche du match là que bon
même en perdant aujourd'hui rien de
grave il y a demain il y a peut-être
encore l'Armageddon enfin peut-être des
7 des doubles 7 des quadruples 7 on ne
sait pas on sait
pas
Magnus carwana les deux autres
exactement l' finale pose car
carwana on est là en tout cas
Fab je suis en joie là je suis heureux
en Jo je suis heureux de l'interview en
fait Mario tu es vachement positif ouais
ouis donné le
smile le côté canadien qui mais les
Canadiens Rapp tu étais là pour la
soirée non tuétais pas là pour avec les
Ch bras la battle contre les parta ah
oui tu étais
là je rappelle plus de rien mais il é
super cool les ou mais il parl pas
français oui
mais mais ce côté positif aussi non
juste là
heureux de tout
quoi demain il y aura des nouvelles
alors oui et non parce qu'en fait le trè
set c'est pas en qure parties c'est en
deux parties donc il y aura des
nouvell de repartir sur des nouvelles
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur tour des 4
pous 5in peut-être F prend
4 alors peut-être ouais peu importe on
verra s'il le joue non mais c'est
vrai non je demande en fait ouais don t
des 4 c'est pas bête euh si tu veux fais
fous C 5 pourquoi pas d'ailleurs au
demeurant euh fou
prend4 fou
prend4 il prend t prends je ferai F5
dame
prend j'échangerai les Dam et je ferai 5
quand même
d'ailleurs
complexe mais bon si les blancs peuvent
solidifier c'est peut-être pas la
manière de
jouer faire F direct
aussiouier ce G4 droit blanc alors à
condition d'arver à ouvrir et F5 rempl
un peu ce rôle d'ouvrir des lignes
d'ouvre
boîte pourquoi pas faire une petite
nulle là Westley
pourquoi ne pas faire une petite nul
là attends ils ont un lien ils ont un
lien meup tu vois je je je sentais qu'
ouais bah voilà je sentais qu'il y avait
encore du mic pour aller s'inscrire
ouais mais ça a l'air sympa
vas-y c'est chest en plus hein dire
qu'il y aura peut-être en plus oui mais
moi jeis enfin ça dérange personne si on
va 2 secondes dessus enfin on laisse la
partie jouer on regarde nous-même aussi
hm hm vas-y on va
voir mais il a fait fou FK de toute
façon ça sent enfin j'envie de Jeet un
est-ce que tu je suis pas forcément
dessus bah voilà g global ch community
fan your local mais c'est vachement bien
M SAF mais en plus c'est ouais mais
c'est vraiment
bien j' très heureux
SP important sport fitness c'est
vachement
bien mais j'ai quasiment envie de mettre
CR un compte de créer une communauté bam
ouais
sympa même si on ve organiser un stage
ou quoi ça peut être sympa en fait bah
ouais mais ça a l'air bien en fa c'est
super bien on découvre des trucs super
bien en fait c'est en vrai c'est
toujours les meilleur sponso c'est comme
la sponso que je vais avoir la semaine
prochaine qui va être la sponso sur le
jeu mobile qu'on voulait tester ah oui
ouais je vais PIR enfin voir ce que
c'est parce que ça me rende des fous et
là c'est une autre un autre truc en fait
tu découvres un truc vraiment bien c'est
pas du tout une sponso à côté quoi c'est
c'est vraiment
intéressant tuas même photographie Mach
c'est vachement
bien mais c'est un truc de génie en fait
fashion and booty
pour ouais pour alienna aussi pour nous
aussi en fait
hein il y a speed dating aussi bravo
part ou mais c'est vachement bien y de
Pary ça cette Cruise avec les DJ va y
aller sur Pary nous c'estant nous
quoi tu peux m aller au musée avec les
gens VIP one testing penthous social
mais c'est complètement nous ça aussi
penthous roof top super c'est nous
[__] en fait c'est nous complètement
partout c'est tout le temps nous en
fait fort new party le mec il est
seul il
su ah mais c'est nous en
fait des trucs animaux enfin c'est très
bien
h dog walk et c'est vachement bien tu
vas promener ton chien avec d'autres
gens March dans Central Parc avec tu
écoutes les oiseaux mais c'est
fantastique en
fait ave the trail machin mais c'est
génial et puis tuas un genre de sécurité
quand même c'est que le site machin
c'estfin c'est ce qu'elle disait tuas
montrer P de Blanche bah truc ouais
c'est que c'est un peu sécurisé dans le
sens où tu tu mites les gens mais il y a
quand même des informations qui sont tu
voisf easy
EAS tu peux aussi savoir ça mais auudelà
de ça j'imagine que du coup tu vois
c'est des trucs qui sont un
peu sécurisé
quoi par un peu cô français quo en
France il pas grand chose un truc vers
Lyon vasy fais
voir hy inéressant point rouge vers Lyon
làit chass
lion.com il
quoi 67 membr quand même c'est qui mais
attends les m en dessous il gens qui
vont
il font
quoi il une partie de non part
c'est
partout qu' font rien ils sont juste
membres pas grandose tu peux pas voir
grand chose parce que tu es pas
membre Genève à Paris un truc
V ch chess in Paris en fait ils ont fait
un chess in toutes les grosses villes
mais ils ont plus de membres parce qu'il
y a plus de Parisiens et Genève ils sont
bien ou lausan ou
quoi 47 bravo mais on devrait faire un
truc pour nos watch Party et puis
peut-être en plus on pe avir des sponso
de génie ouais mais en fait il y a Barc
ou voir s' a
Taline il a rig
oui ils sont
34chent
scan des trucs même chez nous
thérapie Kundalini yoga
class intéressant
ça c'est la chik qui
l'organise non ça a l'air hyper
intéressant non il se pass des trucs
dans la ma
partie bon al dé goouté qu'il y en est
pas à Lille mais bon tu peux le créer je
crois hein tu peux le créer ouais je
pense tu vas être organisateur Meetup tu
vas prendre du galon tout ça c'est très
intéressant mais c'est hyper intéressant
ce
truc tu vois pour notre soirée barbecue
coréen c'est peut-êre être pas mal hein
h je sais pas s'il y a des gens qui sont
intéressés par les candidats on ve faire
une soirée barbecue
coréen chez Madame le chez Madame le
ouais obligation de prendre un barbecue
Corin si vous participez alors
normalement por quand même parce que
c'est que c'est le meilleur bon mais
ceux qui peuvent pas manger de porc il y
a aussi le buf mais on sera un petit peu
déçu niveau gustatif
celui au port est plus plus gûtu plus il
est plus épicé donc plus
intéressant je pense on devra limiter à
20 personnes on est déjà de Mazo
3 il y aura que les meilleurs
quoi mais après le droit d'entrée sera à
40 € je pense mais la barre assez haute
quoi mais la barre assez haute ouais
mais bon après vous allez vous vous
régaler là ah vous allez vous délecter
ouais et Madame l nous fera peut-être
l'honneur de voir un verre de blanc avec
nous à la fin du repas si c'est le
samedi soir si c'est le samedi soir
sinon faut travailler le lendemain et là
bon c'est différent mais c'est grand
honneur madame l qui
oui bon c'est ça ce sera Cann Théodor
chez Madame Lee le petit C oou la canne
donc on sera là avec Fab et donc donc il
y aura le le barbecue courin obligatoire
donc comme je disais port pour ceux qui
peuvent obligatoire ceux qui peuvent pas
bon voilà on sera un peu déçu madame en
fait toujours déçu aujourd'hui on a
mangé buf bon elle nous a pe adressé la
parole mais bon Lenna même Lenna qui
était plus BFF aujourd'hui elle aessé
que quand même port et auudessusce que
c'est plus
piquant le buf est tellement auudessus
niveau qu ouais bon tu es complètement à
côté mais mais ce sera CAN mais bon
voilà consommation
obligatoire en général mais oua petite
poitrine de por c'est une dingon voilà
ok lui lui lui il sera là mais tu
connais madame le frérot VO petit C ou
la CAN tu
connais donc vous tiendra au courant
mais ce sera normalement en avril
pendant les candidats on pourra se
délecter voà on va essayie de trouver
une journée de repos qui va qui va bien
aller il y aura du kimchi bien
évidemment les petits légumes là on on a
pu goûter de la racine de lotus à midi
ouais racine de lotus excellent j'ai
petits chips maintenant aussi de chips
d'alg d'algue ouais on peut manger comme
ça ou tu peux mêre sur du riz
ou on se
délecte quand on sait pas quand mais en
avril bon on saitve que les candidats
c'est annoncé entre le 3 et le 25 donc
entre le 3 et le 25 mais bon faut encore
se mettre d'accord avec Madame
lou on n pas encore quel Meetup hein
mais euh
faut pas que çaatt pendant un congrès
c'est
complexep on va jouer le jeu de Madame l
on espère si pas cette fois ce sera une
autre mais là pour l'instant c'est
l'idée on pour faire une autre chez
roui très bon
kebab serait beau quoi ça ch obligatoire
pour tout le
monde du côté de l c'est S
ouis mais de Lille tu as pas Madame l
quoi
ouis je pense que thodor va descendre de
Paris pour cette soirée de génie c'est
sûr il a super envie quoi c'est ça une
soirée
magnifique faire payer avant ça évite
les surprises la dernière fois ah ouais
ouais non c'est c'est mais de toute
façon il y a que la dernière fois qu'on
a eu des problèmes qu'il y avait un
tournoi d'échec avec César en même temps
donc il y a des gens des échecs
habituels sont venus ceci expliquant
cela c'est la seule fois où on a eu des
problèmes en fait h parce qu' y avait
des gens qui qui jouent en tour d'chec
qui sont venus donc c'était quoi quand
il y avait une te rappell pas c'est P le
tour de can ouais était retrouvé à payer
80 € ou quoi parce que les gens étaient
partis sans payer
h mais parce qu'il y avait des gens du
Tour à d'échec qui étaient venu donc il
avait absolument pas payé c'était nimpe
mais c'est la seule fois où on a eu un
problème j'ai jamais mangé ma chérie
végétarienne oui bon benah elle pourra
prendre elle pourra venir quand même
donc elle commandera un barbecue porc on
pourra se partager avec Fab en
supplément toute façon ça c'est
obligatoire vous êtes obligé de le
commander après vous commz autre chose
une
soupe mise au soupe ouais une soup ell
sont très bien
ou que saisje quoi une
salade en tout cas faudra aller vite vu
que les places vont être ultra
limité
ça devrait faire nul après on va voir
ouais mais Abdou il peut peut-être
embêter parce que hier Naka il avit
trouvé des idées quand même dans la
finale de FO reposé qui a quand même
fini par nul mais bon donc qui
sait il y a une mauvaise qualité d'
aujourd'hui ou j'ai vu mais alors
pourquoi ils sont moins il y a plus
deut-êre qu'ils ont peut-être qu'ils ont
bougé les tables qu'ils ont fait des
efforts ils ont sué des techniciens qui
sont venus rebrancher d'autres choses je
sais pas
moi c'est un peu embêtant en tout cas ça
peut influer sur les niveau de jeu bah
oui on n'est pas sûr que le niveau de
jeu va être optimal contrairement aux
autres jours où c'était vraiment tout
était
parfait ça me gêne un petit
peu après c'est les mêmes conditions
pour les deux joueurs j'ai envie de dire
il faut savoir quand même
s'adapter
mais Wesley qui était tellement
dominateur dans les conditions optimales
est-ce que ça va pas plus le gêner
peut-être que son adversaire ah c'est
possible
ça
ça doit être nul mais c'est vrai que ça
peut être un peu pénible un petit de
plus alors même s'ils sont pas
magnifiques ça compte ça peut aider
Crion passé et
cetera ce fou qui va peut-être arver en
E2 vraiment un beau joueur j'aime bien
ouais il va il va de l'avant il est
sympa à avoir
joué il essae toujours quoi s'il a peut
obtenir un petit truc qui non il va pas
fermer le
jeu c'est un joueur
assaillant je suis à de de quitter le
stream ça dégoûte mais le problème c'est
qu'on sait pas sur quoi il rebondit ah
oui on sais pas B il est tout seul en
fait non mais je il y a en c'est il a
enfin il y a une minute 30 donc je sais
plus de quo on parler
par de kimchi
peut-être c'est gagnant c'était gagnant
pour les blancs il a raté
quoi il a dû rater juste qu'il pouvit
gagner le P en un
mais si S dit à qu et ben en fait non il
a pas qu ou C des 8 ouais donc double
gaffe c'est de nou une partie quiattaque
en fait non mais là bon il y a quand
même la qualité de l'air quoi c'est
peut-être pour ça qui était dégoûé qui
de quitter le stream à cause de la
qualité de l'air euh qui du coup permet
pas à saut de déployer l'étendu de son
jeu dem est-ce qu'il y aura des lives
des Blitz du président championn
d'Europe ah bah je pense sur la chaîne
de son fils
ouais je suppose
hein faudra que tu aillees que tu ailles
voir que tu tiennes au courant sur sur
Twitter sont quand même le troll il av
du sponsor ben non on est vraiment m top
en fait c'est vraiment premier degré là
pour le coup
on va créer un compte et on va un on va
vraiment on va vra vraiment regarder en
fait le truc est vraiment
super et c'est fou en fait tu parles
vraiment premier degré les gens c'est
second degré alors que c'est franchement
jeéis vraiment super Heux de la
conversation et tout quoi c'est ça a
l'air hyper cool des fois dans le sens
inverse pareil tu fais du second degré
et très arrogant c'est ça c'est fou en
fait
mais du coup bon ben bonne question pour
avoir le
[Musique]
cornetou qui essaye en tout cas et qui a
peut-être qui arriver parce que Westley
a plus trop de temps il a moins d'une
minute là il commence à mettre la
pression avec son roi quand
même
climb the moon demande pourquo il y a
une génération d'b super fort bah bonne
question B alors j'imagine qu'ils se
sont bien entourés niveau entraîneur
qu'ils ont investi sur la formation et
et B que ça
paye génération c'est deux joueurs hein
ouais mais de et demi
enfin c'est un peu moins fort les autres
mais ils ont quand même gagné les
Olympiades donc c'est vrai qu'il a lui a
cindarov il a kubf ça joue alors avant
les oubec bon tuas eu Casim un peu tu
sais pas pourquoi comment
mais sinon c'était barsov peut-être le
numéro 2 quoi enfin ça volait pas ha
pareil pas d'offense contre barsov hein
qui éit grand maître et un joueur je
sais pas équivalent à moi mais c'est
comme si tu es numéro 2 de mon pays quoi
enfin tu te dis c'est pas le pays des
génies
quoi et et pour le coup pour le coup
voilà là c'est quand même différent ils
ont Abdou qui clique bien cindarov qui
se bat bien y cuubof peut-être d'autres
je sais pas euh donc j'imagine hein qu'
qu'ils ont su mettre une école d'échec
intéressante s'entourer de bon
entraîneur et euh et voilà faire quelque
chose peut-être détatique et pas chacun
fait son truc dans son coin et au petit
bonheur la chance
quoi après faudra voir quand même en a
d'autres long terme c'est peut-être
juste du bol en
fait mais tu as raison pour moi il y a
des
ch les gens qui sont d'accord ça l'air
sympa je sais pas pourquoi les gens
disent que je suis second enfin c'est en
fait il r second degré non mais tu
pourrais l'être mais tu l' pas en fait
donc ça pourrait mais tu ne peux pas
savoir mais là je il suff juste de
regarder par soi-même de se faire un
avis ça se voit que c'est vraiment cool
comme
idée mais là non ça en fait ça se voit
si je suis second degré mais
c'est pour les gens qui sont très
habitués mais là non non c'est vraiment
vraiment cool puis maril était vraiment
très sympa en
plus peut-être de faire E3
là il y a le pion à 5 c'est ça le
problème en fait rest sinon n pu il veut
pas faire quelques secondes ou mais il a
raison il a raison il peut tourner
récupérer avec les 3 secondes
hein
ouais compliqué c'est final avec des
trop de fou
quoi il est revenu de l'autre côté si
forces à jouer G5 c'est quand même ça
bloque les H5 ou quoi maintenant il va
attendre il va encore attendre pas trop
en faire là non plus hein rage 3
peut-être ou
quoi genre de truc si tu forces trop r
qu'il veut fout des
7 peut-être pu on revient
il voulait fou a 7 fou D4 tu je je je
sais pas il essaie de faire des trucs là
il va faire fou G6 un petit E3 qui
pourra passer peouis c'est ça peêre 3 E2
ouais il tend des pièges non mais je dis
faut vraiment se méfier qu fait des
trucs l'air de rien il va peut-être
faire fou D4 fou D2
E3 et puis on prend lere non ouais je
sais mais
bon il va faire fou B si
alors on fout un au cas
où il va revenir
vir TS de TR quand
même mais c'est bien joué mais j'adore
en fait comment il joue il prend tous
les risques mais il prend vraiment des
risques hein il va te faire E4 mais
attention de pas se faire contrer sur le
P H6 he quand
même il y a peut-être un peu tropé là ça
va encore mais oui ouais mais c'est les
blancs jou le
G
bon ah c'est
trop5 et compagnie pas prendre H6 faire
juste
pleutreen c'est trop je pens qu' fait F
non F il peut
pas 5
TR
fois quel dommage mais partie sympa
SR c'est bon il faire fouer 7 non il
veut pas faire TR fois ouais mais je fou
TR fois plus jamais
là
il veut faire fou2 mais bon il aura fou
fou là il va faire fou il va faire fou
7on il va faire
non fou
C3 ça put F8 non6 ça change tout
là bon cétait
drôle il est vraiment courageux
quoiain malgré le temps de moin du coup
il avir la M de
plus il aura pas pu faire
toutesretours très amusanto ro des de as
je su pas sûr que le temps change grand
chose en
fait
bien joué ça
ah petite répète il prendra 4 un
jour ok être mon nul encore mais ça joue
marrant cette
game là sil veut vous prendre
F6
ouais pe faire rien enfin j'aurais dit
fou 7 du coup il peut pas faire A6 prend
C3
A7 il y a fou B6 fou E6 fou F6
ou c'est gagnant pour les blancs
maintenant d'après
l'ordi c'était peut-être pas à cause de
ça non
ça l' pas mal il va gagner g5ouis il va
remettre le fond F6 va F4 après il va
gagner
incroyable qui va s'en vouloir d'avoir
pris tous ces risques là avant mais bon
pe pas sans vouloir d'être un joueur
ambitieux65 ça
ferme F ou tu peux tout échanger
ou c'est jouur qui a essayé de gagner
qui est puni
cont il a le seum
ouais dur de battre au sa hein Carl qui
a fini par gagner avec une d de moins
mais
euh mauvaise cas ouis faire F7 ou ouais
F7 sur tour8 ah tuas d F6
ais tu fais les échecs ou
un peu dommage F6 alors mais tu es
complètement
foutu il fallait
juste
non mais tu les doue
ouais mais tu as pas de ce pour le roi
donc c'est très con quand même C dame
D8 ah oui mais c'est ce qu'il a fait
mais c'était encore ah [__] il donne s
sur échec on a
ouais bon c'est trop c'est énorme comme
gaffe ouais ça c'est énorme comme gaffe
ouais tu fais juste G5 G4 et bon bon ben
écoutez les amis on se retrouve jeteer
un œil à meup créer un profil peut-être
et vous on en reparle après et puis ben
on suivra la la suite de ces matchs à
tout à
[Musique]
l'heure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amis on est on est reparti avec le
match
Abd AC les pièces
blanches grandd la structure de Bad
qu'on a sous les yeux il est mené au
scord
oua contre le cours du jeu au vu de la
première partie
mais
quelque
part puni par un excès d'engagement
quelque part c'est la force de Wesley
aussi ouais beaucoup aurit pu flancher
puis il s'est remis à jouer le gain
quand même à la fin finalement Wesley
oui quand il l'opportunité il
essayé la parti mag il a gagné du fond
du trou ouais Magnus mais bon c'est
carwana qui lui a donné c'est étonnant
mais écoutez c'est comme
ça beaucoup de gaffe dans ce
tournoi
étonnamment on pour s'attendre un coup
comme A5 peut-être ici traitement
moderne de la
position que je jouerai pas en fait moi
je reste un vieux quoi mais
voir c'est qui
réfléchit
mais zé donc il a besoin de nul regarde
ppm qui augmente c'est de
pire normement le P augment quand il y a
plus de gens dans une salle moins ils
sont plus
augment qu' aurait pas plus de
monde je regard sur offici est-ce qu'il
y aurait pas du public en fait sans
qu'on le sans que nous on les su cas
moins de public qui suit le tournoi là
pour ces demi-finales les audiences sont
en berne malheureusement peut-être que
les gens étaient là pour les armesagedon
surtout et là sachant qu'il y aura pas
d'armedon aujourd'hui peêtre ça ça les
ennuie un petit peu pere que ça les
dégoûte je suis en train de regarder
mais oui j'imagine doit y avoir du
public parce que sinon euh comment
expliquer cette qualité de l'air ouais
claque tout devient rouge
hein la chaleur la qualité de l'air mais
25°gr moi je trouve que c'est chaud hein
le
PPM véellement he que l'humidité qui est
encore
passable
toi tu
penses et qui a ramené le F E7 donc il a
pas envie de laisser B4 si facilement à
son adversaire et ça peut
s'entendre non j'arrive pas à voir je je
je reste un tout petit peu sur la offici
parce que je je suis étonné je me dis
oui il y a peut-être du public qui
arrive pour les demi-finales ça paraît
très pas illogique
hein après il peut être un peu bruyant
peut-être c'est vrai comment faire si
jamais il donne les
coups cherche des infos sur le public
hein les AM
amis à mon avis il y en a pas hein mais
bon je cherche la je je cherche une
explication la qualité de l'air je suis
désolé pe dire que je suis un genre de
détective ouais tu fais une
investigation alors tour a été joué on
peut sattend un coup comme cavalier F6
ou fou D6 pour remplacer le
fou
ben je vais écrire à
Nathan C F6 joué par wesle peut-être son
adversaire vont profiter pour mettre son
cavalier en E5 vu que le contrôle de la
caise a été un petit peu
laissé peut-être un plan de pilsbury
après avec F4
pour maintenir ce cavalier 5 en tout cas
j'ai écrit
hein tu tu metes l'enquête tu veux
savoir je metre
l'enquête ne vous inquiétez pas mesdames
et messieurs je suis sur le coup on va
essayer d'arriver au bout de cette
histoire de qualité
ou on est étonné quand même ah là ils
ont tout le bon matériel ils ont les
boîtiers et cetera donc en fait le
boitier ne peut rien faire pour toi il
peut juste t'avertir
après à to d'ouvrir la fenêre après au B
d'un moment genre leier va pas aller
ouvrir la fenêtre pour toi non donc
là que fait la police
quoi ben genre c'est très simple pour
régler un problème de CO2 il te suffit
d'aérer la
pièce est-ce que mettre une plante verte
ça pourrait aider je pense pas non deux
ples verte je crois pas que les PL de
vert en fait mais même pas du tout en
fait c'est
terrible
regarde ça fait que augmenter c'est de
bien en
bien je pense qu'on est pas au bout de
nos surprises pour cette journée là les
conditions très très
difficiles les joueurs déjà ont été mis
à rue d'épreuve par 3 4 jours de
compétition déjà samedi dimanche lundi
mardi 4 jours on Arve au 5e jour de
compétition les organismes r d'épreuve
et
là c'est un peu le drame l'air se met à
manquer température est élevée 25°gr
c'est vraiment chaud en plus c'est dur
je pense que vraiment il fallait aller
se préparer en Amérique du Sud peut-être
en Amazonie pour pour être prêt pour ce
tournoi je sais pas si certains on ont
fait justement pour pour être paré 5000
ppm valeur limite d'exposition et là ils
sont à combien ils sont à
ça peut-être en exé et ouvrir une h à la
concentration oui mais vu qu'il fait
déjà trop chaud tu pourrais régler d'une
pierre de cou le et le CO2 et la
chaleur on dit pas de laisser ouvert
toute la journée hein tu laiss ouvert un
petit peu le temps de de tempérer tout
ça en tout cas pour les ppm je me rends
pas compte de ce que ça fait mais
mais pour les 25°gr ça je me rends
compte que c'est trop
chaudou en tout cas on suit cette partie
VO qui
réfléchit
ah c'est passé à 500 CPM d'un seul coup
ils ont dû tout ouvrir mais l'humidité a
baissé de manière assez
sèche il s'est passé quelque chose là
Fab il y a quelqu'un qui est
intervenu bah c'est sûr qu'ils ont tout
ouvert
et ils ont mis une clim peut-être je
sais pas ils ont fait un truc en tout
cas ça ça a changé mais vraiment du tout
au tout et là on va voir la qualité de
jeu fa d'un coup va va augmenter en
flèche tu vois 1000 à 2 BM concentration
qui cons la mauvaise qualité de l'air et
qui provoque une sensation
d'engourdissement
ouais il était pas bien en fait ben non
je trouais un peu lent pour jouer ses
coups justement un peu
engourdi là il va re d'un coup beaucoup
plus frais
peut-être marrant que ça pass pass de
1300 à 500 comme ça en l'espace de 3 4
secondes je sais pas si dans le chat on
sait comment est possible comment est
possible ouis est-ce que c'est vraiment
ils ont ouvert les fenêtres mais ça
aurait pas influé sur mais ça influé
aussi sur l'humidité qui a baissé d'un
seul coup Mo 6 % d'humidité dans l'air
en l'espace de 3 secondes un truc de
clim où ils ont manché un autre boîtier
ou je sais pas je sais pas je sais pas
ils ont pété la boîte
Go estce qu'il aurait
déplace je sais pas comment ça a pu ça a
pu arriver en tout cas on l'a vécu en
direct à ce moment peut-être fa mettre
un petit replay sur pour voir quel
moment exact c'est
arrivé a les 25 points d'humidité qui
sont
qui clique en tout cas il est pas
engourdi il VI envoyer
F4 pourquoi pas F5 à venir
ensuite est-ce que c'est Mme qualité
d'air sur l'autre table
est-ce que c'est non je pense qu'il y a
un boîtier pour toute la
salle normalement
oui le capteur fait peut-être des
mesures toutes les 5 minutes c'est
possible on va voir on va
attendre avec
curiosité
Abdou qui a le se
il a une belle position quand
même position sympa he sympa
jouable une petite avance sympa la
pendule aussi à noter
toujours on va voir ce que va réussir à
à nous conccta dou ça dans cette partie
Fab écoute là il a bien mis toutes ses
pièces on all dev voir he si vous jouez
avec C5 ou plutôt viser l'ilroi
et je sa pas essayer de pousser du G4 et
cetera on verra
Fab al ce soir un magnifique place
season oui j'ai
hâte il y a une soupe poulet harira pour
toi ah très bien
marocaine non
ouais c'est plus sa ouais pour bien se
purifier j'ai pas besoin bien manger à
midi mais
bon tout cas on a faire un match très
qualitatif
extraordinaire aujourd'hui encore avec
Abd qui a été champion du monde mais qui
qui sait
taper les
dents
solide j'ai regardé un épisode la Ligue
des Justiciers avant le stream c'est
quoi
ça du
batmanoi sont
là
incroyable qui se
blesseaer il est pas très bien il est un
peu au bord de viier de la mort à
l'hôpital bon faut le [__] dans la
flotte il va reprendre bah il est
d'hôpital le soigner j'arrive pas à lui
faire de piqure il a la peau trop dur
bon il su et là tout d'un coup il y a
Batman qui arrive et j'ai la solution et
ilit euh et alors il a un truc avec de
l'eau il le mett dedans il se soit
instantan oui oui bah oui d qu'il est
dans l'eau il est très fort comment
as-tu deviné
B c'est vrai que c'est pas pas
facile
du coup on est soulagé Aquaman
survécu qu dans l'eau il est très très
fort sil sort de l'eau il est un peu
moins il fort quand même ou pas
vite faitof plus que moi
[Musique]
mais ilimpressionne personne
quoi mais bon je sais pas enfin la jusce
leag son très fort enfin juste en fait
tu mets juste Superman tout seul de
toute façon il est fonce tous
ouis mais ça qu'on voit TR animé c'est
qu'il se fait défoncer Superman des fois
par des débiles finis bah peut-ês ont de
la Crypton sur eux non mais par des
armes complètement débiles ça m'énerve à
chaque fois c'est pas vraiment possible
en fait mais c'est pas possible non il y
a rien qui peut le non non il est trop
dessus bah c'est un peu comme dans The
Boys
ouais mais en plus fort ENF est encore
plus fort je ve dire mais personne ne
peut pas Superman non non bah al après
cé la kryptonite même toi tu peux quoi
c'est
dire se il suffoque tout seul quoi il tu
vois ça il très très mal mais mais il
est pas du tout dans les machins de
Thanos et tout non c'est pas le même
univers
Marvel mais ils sont pas potes avec
Batman euh bah du coup dans jusce League
si oui mais genre globalement sinon pas
quoi si ça vaon il y a un truc où il se
m un peu sur la gueule mais sinon ils
sont ça
va le mec il vole il la vision laser il
te fait des lasers il coupe les trucs il
la vitesse de l'éclair il est in
touchable tu tape il s'en fout c'est
c'est du c'est du
béton qu'est-ce que tu veux faire quoi
il voit à travers les murs il fait
tout déjà voler c'est pas
malin mais par contre la cryptonite le
défonce ouais
complètement mais sinon ouais peut-être
tu mets pas trop au soleil aussi il suit
un
peu le soleil le régénère quoi pouvoir
revienne donc autant Aquaman tu le fous
dans la flotte il va tout de suite mieux
Superman un petit rayon de soleil tout
va
bien mais dans la flotte Aquaman il est
qui le enfin Superman b b Aquaman dans
la
flotte en mê temps il va jamais trop
dans la flotte mais oui j'imagine il
serait très fort ou au pire il se met
auessus de la flotte il envoie des rons
laser partout c'est même pas quand tu le
touches
quoi et super
woman alors je la connais pas trop mais
Wonder Woman Wonder Woman ouais ou c'est
fort Wonder Woman mais moins que
Superman dans ceUc il y a un mec vert
aussi genre de martien ah ouais mais il
est complètement nul quoi il explose au
ça lui non c'est
conis je connais pas du tout
lui il pas fait ah non c'est
pas il l'a fait il est reparti bonçon je
peux pas faire autre
chose un peu comme Piccolo dans Dragon
Ball
quoi il est vert il est là mais bon
c'est pas trop ce qu'il veut quoi ci qui
c'est le green lanterne ouais je sais
pas TR ce qu' fait LNE
gre
est-ce qu'il y a flash aussi qui court
un peu par moment
non là j'ai pas trop compris euh Aquaman
il était dans atlanti je sais pas ce
qu'il
foutait je connaissais pas moi Aquaman
en
fait ouais non mais conna vite fait
enfin il ENF je connaissais son
existence mais bon on sa pas trop ce
qu'il fait ouais ouais non il règne
ouais sur le sur royaume aquatique on va
dire il av un plan de génie en
fait est méchant ouais en fait il
voulait faire chauffer le pôle nord et
le Pôle Sud pour défoncer la
glaceasse un rat de marée sur les terres
et tout soit sous l'eau quoi un plan
diabolique
quoi pourquoi c'est pas juste un pion B
c'est juste un pion hein ouais mais bon
ça peut être chaud F5 F5 bien joué
probablement si tu prends de fois 4 et
je sais pas mettre le frond D5 te faire
F6 rentrer les cases
blanches57 peux prendre 4 faire F6
peut-être maintenant peut-être on peut
prendre
déteste ça l'air
cata
si tu prends 4
prend68 il prend
[Musique]
5 s je
connerour mais il pas faire
mieux une m sur le cavalier en fait plus
d'A C cavalier quoi pas
touché
incroyable tout
ça donc j'ai regardé ça ouais h avec
sopia ou non non tout seul
[Musique]
hein non mais très bienud me mettre sur
le coup la prochaine
fois
ouais il y a Wonder Woman aussi alors
dans le truc
ouais qui me fume ce mec vert quoi il
écrase au sol quoi c'est wou il est
nulissime j'avais bien aimé le premier
film mais c'est des trucs pour
m'endormir en fait
h que tu es pas du tout frustré de rater
ce qui se passe un peu quand même
ouais mais tu sais pas si si les
glaciers vont fondre est-ce que est-ce
que est-ce que à qui ça va aller enfin
tu es un peu tu te questionnes quand
même
tu en suur quoi g can tu permet de
matérialiser tout ce à quoi il
pense faut quand même qu'il fasse gaffe
quoi
ouis B c'est 7 6 si on prend F6 c'est
terminé il va égaliser Abdou mais il
domine he ce match pour le
moment il domin
ou là l'umité de l'air de ouais descent
très dangereusement là 18 % pe plus plus
sec quoi ouais ça commence à être trop
sec
là faudrais pas qu'il meure asséché
quoi
non mais il do mettre la clim à fond là
je crois ouais
pourisselair je sais pas qui en charge
mais ouais
c'est qu' Meur asséché
quoi non mais vraiment je trouve
l'événement fantastique parfait mais
s'il y a un truc à changer peut-être
c'est que quelqu'un gère mieux
l'air tu trop chaud quoi mais je sais
pas fait trop chaud passer
humide le PPM le truc enfin bon il faut
vraiment quelqu'un qui soit dédié à
cette tâche et il fasse tout ça bien bon
après sinon tout est tout est vraiment
parfait quoi quelqu'un dit moi c'est les
échecs pour endormir tu t'en fous de ce
que tu rates mais c'est vrai en plus non
tu es pas le
seul nous aussi en fait en fait quand on
fait beaucoup d'échecs du coup bon ouais
non mais je bon je mets pas les échequs
mais des petites vidéos pour dormir
c'est pas mal
ouais c'est demain la finale ou là non
demain c'est le deè attention ou il y
aura peut-être d'ailleurs un 3è hein
pourqu il fait C5 parce qu'il veut
s'activer ESS de faire fou C6 et activer
ses pièces quoi quit à être mal
autantactiver un peu et laisser
un un petit euh malentendu peut-être
quoi qume avec son sere il peut faire
des
oui des sortes de
[Musique]
missiles mais le mec vert en fait touj
pas compris
euh son intérêt en fait ou je sais pas
trop pas ouais c'est pas le plus célèbre
de tous
quoi
ou il fait le 6 F6
ouais comme tu aimes bien
ouais
ok il tente il tente il du coup c'est
quoiah c'est F6 ouais ah mais bon ah il
va l'avir mais tuas tour un tour des 7
en
fait en fait ça termine la part sur le
champ j'avais aussi en
fait c'était pas très dur si j'avais
aussi c'est que c'était pas très
dur bon quand même la très bonne
nouvelle de cette victoire c'est ça nous
garantit qure parties aujourd'hui ah on
a un peu peurre que les match soi courts
ouais et là
matrixé tu parles en Bou du mec vert
ouais mais parce qu'il me il
complètement explosé frérot alors c'est
quoi son nom je vais essayer d'aller
trouver ça justice leag martien c'est
martien peut-être il est martien ouais
ouis je sais c'est le martien mais
est-ce qui s'appelle le martien
déjà Martian Hunter ah c'est le c'est
c'est chasseur martien peut-être c'est
lui
là man Hunter également connu sous son
nom martien de John Jones alias John
Jones est un superhéros de bande
dessinée écréé par Joseph samashon et
Joe Serta il appartient à l'univers DC
Comics il apparaît pour la première fois
dans l'épisode ce strange experiment of
docteur je sais pas lequel voir doctor
herdel en 1955 donc ça fait déjà Mo
qu'il est
là il est moche quoi
euh pouvoirs spéciaux il vole il a la
super force rapidité régénération
télékinésie
télépathie intangibilité invisibilité
longévité métamorphose ah il fait quand
même pas truc Mme chose c'est un alien
euh voilà et il a apparu dans les films
Man of Steel et Batman Superman l'aube
de la justice et le Zack sneider Justice
League et dans les séries dans
Smallville et
supergir Smallville euh sympa ouais c
notre notre adolescence nonile ouais
ouais tout à fait géographie fictive
alors pourquoi
fictive alors il était scientifique sur
son monde il est accidentellement
téléporté sur Terre par le cerveau robot
du professeur Marc
ardel d'accord et euh et pr il retourne
pas dans sur sa planète ben en fait le
seul qui est capable de d'opérer sur le
cerveau robot succourbe de la crise
cardiaque sous l'émotion donc là il est
il est bloqué mais il peut pas voler
jusqu'à sa planète non là il se retrouve
coincé sur terre c'est écrit en
attendant que son peuple qui travaille
au projet du vaisseau spatial star ride
atteigne la terre John Jones explore sa
planète d'adoption constatant le taux
élevé de criminalité et de CO2 peut-être
aussi il devient inspecteur de police s
l'identité de John Jones ok alors comme
tous les martiens il une force
surhumaine et télépathe et métamorphe
c'est super quoi aussi une vision
thermique
la structure moléculaire pourevenir
invisibleire bravo Monsieur
quoi ça il il peut égaliser avec D C6
attention il l'
trouvé quand même un point faible il est
vulnérable au
feu un gros point fa besoin de trouver
crypt ou quoi Flam il est mal quoi ah
ouais ça le ferme complètement en
fait
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
scientifiques parmi les super-héros
bon ça reste probablement gagnant pour
les blancs en pratique donc bref
ok Lana dans Smallville ouais c'est
toute notre enfance ça Lana dans
Smallville ouais cétait qui déjàactrice
je sais plus mais
sympathique mais malheureusement clarken
qui finira pas avec
elle je me rappelle plus il fait quoi et
c'est l'utor qui fin avec elle non ah
mais je sais pas trop qui finit avec
mais de toute façon lui après il part
Métropolis c'est ouais ouais c'est
vrai ça y mais en fait c'est sa cousine
la
journaliste je me rappelle moins toi tu
es plus super que moi je regardais hein
mais je me rappelle
moins
superhéros préféré Mor
le8 il va gagner
Abd c'est s y il va
gagner je sais pas si se mari ou pas
avec lis l
mais son grand amour
après
c'est beau l'amour le
Fab même quand on est
superhéros s rapproché du roi faut
éviter de se mettre en
G7 D7 va être joué mais ça va pas
suffire il y aura dame prend des7 et F7
F7 ouais ça fait mal d échec R 2 et plus
d'échec attendez un d'ailleurs et la
prise et
F7 facile pour Abdou
facile pour un tel c'est le seul gain
après mais c'est quand même relativement
simple et il l'a et il l'a évidemment
bravo devra abandonner côté
Westley wle qui risque de tomber
d'ailleurs belle partie d'Abdou qui
égalise un partout on aura donc quatre
parties aujourd'hui oh peut-être aussi
quatre partie de l'autre côté parce que
Fabiano est peut-être en train
d'égaliser
aussi il a les blancs Fabiano
Fabiano de plus pour l'instant déjà
quand même et en plus le à qui prend
l'espace dans leamp advers prendre le
às ride on s coup comme t arrivant ça
pourrait ça pourrait faire le TA
attention jamais facile à battre dans la
partie précédente quand Mme que fa+ 7
qu'and Mme perdu donc tout peut arriver
interacction qu'on apprprécie plus les
parties longues bon
nonf il en a peut-être tout autant hein
peut tout autant ouais c'est pas un jeu
facile les échecs hein il souvent des
erreurs et c'est comme ça he il y en a
des plus explicables que d'autres des
ouais il y en a particulièrement
beaucoup dans ce tournoi quand même
oui pas que dû à la cadence c'est on
sait pas trop ce qui se passe
mais j pas très
bien
seer descend à la
pendule pas qu'
gagneage 2 il va attaquer ce
pion
D6 peut-être k D8 le cas dispo il pour
encore rebondir en B7 il sera
complètement jeu mais au moins pas
perdu pas simple à conclure en fait mais
bon tu as aussi des tours des de au
chèqu hein pour
revenir si tu as envie
7 attaque le
cavalier est-ce qui fait t de est-ce qu'
fait cavalier C6 qui
B7 remque B7 c'est peut-être pas si
débile hein pour faire B4 ensuite il
fait tour des de il est en train de ser
les pinceaux non Fabiano là is un
peu il a un pion de plus il reste
gagnant et peut-être B4 B5 et k C6
retour mais B4 peut-être ouais qui6 qui
C6
si tu
t'installes cas j'espère unectire de
Fabiano pour espérer deux arm
aujourd'hui ah oui oui bien sûr bien
s il égaliser pas trop mal au temps pour
ça jouer
fa tour des 5 centralise la tour
des
coup
éch je pense que c'était ça son
idée quand même ton cavalier tus tu fais
aprs il vient tellement de gafé dans la
partie précédente qu'il doit suer quand
même non là il doit savoir que rien est
taquis il prend du cavalier pour
peut-être aller en G6 non pas du tout
alle té vite att vite maintenant ouais
il faut le faire c'est bien
joué il va prendre la 7 revenir en B5 ça
devrait
aller mais j'aurais fait pe tour V moi
c'est bien tenté pour essayer de faire
cavalier F5 ou quoi bon ça marche pas du
tout
mais
[Musique]
pe c'est une tentative quoi
ok B5 le pion avance et 7 à 8 ça paraî
imparable
maintenant peut pas y avoir de perpè là
non trop de cas li autour de lui
Magnus qui va abandonner ça fait un
partout dans les deux matchs éoutez on
se retrouve bientôt peut-être dans 10
minutes on revient on sait pas trop le
le temps de pause entre les parties mais
on essaie de surveiller ça et d'être là
pour le début de la prochaine ronde à
tout de suite les
amis
[Musique]
doesn't look like much but neither would
a Sicilian defense to the unrained E
this is a performance enhancer you don't
don't see it how about now manage your
air quality sharpen your performance
change the game with air things new
opening for your wall is here capture
new major pieces on unique metal posters
from displate now with the official
collection from Chess.com Mount them in
seconds with a toolfe magnet kit and
swap them whenever you like make your
move get an exclusive discount on all
metal posters shop now with the code
chess
[Musique]
displate.com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça ça repart on s'est fait un peu
dépasser mais en fait ah parce que les
parties commencent en
décaler donc euh bah c'est bien voir
l'arrivée des joueurs Fab
voilà du caméraman
aussi caméra
épaule
jour bien mis là o il
fallaitité qui qui est en train de
repartir non non de sécrou
bon ah oui
catastrophe
une soufflerie à
fond asséché
l'air beau match en tout
cas on att pour pour
commencer va arriver de manière
féine voilà d'illeurs alors
il est très heureux
W j'a bien son petit t-shirt chemise
rose
oui il me semble déjà utilisé pendant le
tournoi salut va bien en tout
cas
pardon et c'est
reparti
am un petit peu d'avance par rapport à
nous on est sur la bonne page 45 F3
att pas
partie ah il y a eu
ouais j'ai compris en fait le truc a pas
été mis à jour sur le fait qu' que les
parties
non bref c'est une Espagnole
classique ce que joue
C3 en tout cas Abdou en aant je D6
montre son intention de ne pas jouer un
Marchall il joue quand même à 4 alors en
général on peut jouer fou G4 làdessus
avec les Noirs d'habitude on peut pas
dans l'antimartial puisquon a fait rock
et qui a 4 et qui encore un en D7 G4
permet à la fois développer le fou et de
défendre la tour parce que mine de rien
ce C4 menace à prend B
avec un clouage Fab voilà donc hier on
avait vu un peu une partie bah celle
entre Maxime et Carlsen comment ça se
passe contre les Noirs joue B4 même qui
peut être jouable tour B8 c'est une
autre option mais ça peut concéder la
colonne A au blanc s ont envie de faire
aomber voilà donc chaque quoi ses
avantages et ses défauts et qui a donc
décidé de jouer t B8 de son
côté joli coup coup de protection
a prend B logique donc voilà pour
s'ctroyer cette colonne A sans à faire
trop d'effort avec notre tour en la
bougeant ailleurs et il joue C3
maintenant donc on vair une position
classique d'espagnol mais sans les pion
a et la colonne pour les blancs ce qui
est quand même un petit peu avantageux
on avait déjà vu Magnus jou un peu de la
sorte contre NPO et Pasir tellement de
problème même si
visuellement ça bien pour les blancs un
peu dégueu visuellement
d'avoir une Espagnole normale mais en
ayant la en aant inodu à 4
B8 c'est quand même plutôt mieux pour
les blancs quoi tour B8 c'est pas le
coup de l'année en soir alors les n
pouront peut-être faire B4 B ber réduire
le champ de les ch
mais en tout cas les Blancs ont pris le
centre ce pion D4 quime D5 gagner le
cavalier attention sur coup comme F G4
pour donner envie D5 arrive donc les
doiventivent réagir donc soit prendre en
des4 soit bouger la dame bouger la tour
bouger quelqu'un pour ce cavalier a une
case en 4 D5 se barre
ouais il all les prendre de l'eau j'ai
l'impressionir très soif he vu le la
sécheresse de l'air c'est normal qu'il
se sent
assoifé atten va pas trop boire d'un
coup non plus he je pense c'est mieux de
boire par à coup des petites lampées les
unes après les autres mais pe s'asperger
ouais avec le bidon comme fly
Landis il s'asperge à cause de la
sécheresse
quoi déjà un petit peu en difficulté
après cette ouverture de de
Westley
CIS qu'il y a le public aussi qui vienne
avec du brumisateur qui le des pistolets
haut faudra leur donner il a choisi de
faire prender donc s'il peut s'entendre
bien sûr maintenant en cas D5 on aura au
moins la classe B4 pour le cavalier et
on pourra préparer un coup de pion C par
la suite et là on pourrait peut-être
même penser à à fou G4 comme ça en cas
de D5 bien sûr on peut même sauter en E5
avec le
cavalier il fait
D5 ok ça avec les j'aime bien jouer ave
E5 dans ces cas de Figur
personnellement le cavalier adverse
vient en E4 et on peut faire c C3 ou2
pour pour essayer de provoquer des
échanges et ensuite ramener le fr C de
direction l roi et ça fume cette idée de
de bidon
[Rires]
quoi ça fait du bien Deger un peu ça
teur met les ID en place déjà par comm
àer 20 minutes 20 25 minutes
Chud tu prends ton bidon
quoi
qui qui est moins sûr de jouer au 5 que
moi
qui regarder
C3 il hésite
voilà il envisage ses
options moi je suis quand même content
de Nobe il joue toujours l'attaque
toujours le gain j'aime vraiment ce
joueur joueur plaisant
ses manch coloré il sera jamais top
mial juste bien pour arnaquer ouais
comprends vraiment
rien c'est un puma je crois son pull bah
j'espère hein c'est le sponsor ah bah il
a peut-être le drit de mettre ses trucs
perso non
ou par qu'il me semble que le truc blanc
là c'est le Puma qui qui se déploie
plein pattes
quoiuc mais je vois pas Westley en Puma
non non Wesley il a fait 5 comme je pas
il aime bien ses vestes non genre de
blazer il mais pour très bien PUM
classique
ou c'est un puma colombien un peu ou
lituanien enfin je sais pas trop les
couleurs mais tu sens qu' peut
bondir parce que so il a toujours cet
ensemble il adore l'ensemble laser ouais
il dérange pas trop
classique pourquoi changer une équipe
qui
gagne j'ai l'impression de toujours le
voir avec le
même le macoutrement
is C beau quoi je tu pourrais prendre
les gels
énergétiquesite les fringu à fond
ouais bah ouais tu faut réfléchir un peu
en danseuse quoi tu dans de l'épaule tu
vois que tu es dans le dur c'est un peu
Naka ça
ouais ça serait bon un genre descheque
manager ton joueur tu vois sa Bar de
conc qui ba tuas rill quo ritaille ouais
du coup tuas un autre gars qui vient qui
lu apporte il se ravitaille à fond tu
vois son niveau de calcul remonte tout
va très bien là il voit
tout après il y a plus d'énergie le
barre bleu descend et toutes les barres
en
bas complet propose nul propose
nul c'est un beau jeu s des créateur de
jeu belle idée
ici
tu feris des pics de forme o il est
meilleur est-ce qu'il prépare le grand
chest tour ou la Coupe du Monde ou enfin
selon les joueurs sonelon le
profil profil de
parties très bien ça un très beau jeu
quoi tu l'aider pour les prépas un peu
lui trouvé un second
an c'est B il a des points de mémoire le
C oublie suis à chaque fois tu prends un
super second an et mais il oublie tout
quoi il oublie tout
quoi très beau jeu hein ouais tu trop le
cré un jour quoi fa manager qu tu su
tout le temps en fait tuis ta ve de
seconde tjs le con fait que de la merde
merde il a encore oublié
quoi tu tu as décidé aussi c'est c'est
tourno important ouais c'est ça c'est-
que tu plutôt de championnat du monde
que tu plutôt la
Cillas à fond ou je pense tu dois faire
k à fond après tour internet du C est-ce
que tu prends le risque de tricher ou
quoi ouis un coup par partie un coup par
tu as des jauges de de combi tu peux
tricher ou pas tricher full triche tu
vois selon contre qui tu joues
aussi
je sis que tu peux avoir un rôle d'agent
où tu peux passer des coups de fil pour
arranger des parties tu peux organiser
des tournois tu peux circifi Tapp en
Inde tu machins
tu marque des points un peu pour se
qualifier là tu peux accuser les autres
de tricher aussi sur Twitter après les
partiescoup de ris ça don quoi ce
jugement il y a en vrai tu peux accuser
de triche après une game il do payer
petit truc quand même non mais c'est pas
pour l'accusation parce qu'il a quitté
le tournoi ah bah oui
forcément il la T8 is je crois qu'il
égalise Abdou il joue vraiment bien cet
Abdou pas faire un tour à 3
ici alors pourquoi pas joli
coup après tu ESS de coulisser ouais
parce que est prendre à 8 ça amène la
dame qui va bien défendre vers4 qui peut
rentrer elle-même tour à 3 tu es là quoi
tu mets des points
Vess su obligé de d'être dans les
chiotes tu veux bien les entraîner à la
marche aussi pour le
concours c'est que ce soir du coin de
l'œil on pourra suivre magnifique
Borussia Dortmund PSG très beau match
c'est Pasche manager c'est mafia manager
ouais tu es
làon c'estchec manager
quoi il a pris en V bon la dame va
reprendre bien
placer peut-être qu' B3 bon il joue dame
plutôt très beau aussi tu tuas un mode
où tu es organisateur de tournois tu
fais que des tournois de merde les mec
te fil du fre tu sa pas trop pourquoi
bats quoi tu doas chercher des profils
de joueurs pour bien qu' des normes dans
tes tournois ou ah c'est beau ouais trou
des joueurs qui vendent des games là
trouver des m mec surclassé qui jou
super mal mais qui encore c'est
be ah ça y qui est en train de quoi tu
dois aussi gérer
ça
ce sera un beau jeu en tout cas mais
ouais enfin très très technique du dur
de tout gérer quoi je
trouve
C5 al j'imagine que l'idée d'Abdou sur
PRC faire fou pran et si les blanc
prennent T 4 qu' prend pion prend fou
prend fou prend dame prend d prend t
prend faire k D3 en fin de variant
attaquant F2 le fou C1 et sur un coup
comme fou E3 on pourraitchanger et aller
prendre B2 liquidant pas mal le jeu mais
bon peut-être on pourrait à la fin quand
mmeir une finale avec 4 contre
3 sur la mêl ce serait un petit eSport
peut-être quand même à Wesley on
verra
merci syvan pour pour le message on n
pas le melon n pas le melon oui bon Fab
non mais moi to tu es toxique moi je
suis toxique et j'ai le melon de
ouf très toxique aussi d'ailleurs moi
non la communauté en général oui manque
de
respect c'est respect je sais très
irresectueuse commter c'est
làon jeens voulait faire fou prend oua
qu'on tout prendre leire su donc fou 3
dessus oua mais j'avais la même variante
je Racon mes conneries pr tour 3 prend2
tour B3 on B5 puis bon on ESS nul mais
ou mais bon tuétais peut-être oigé de
faire C5 du coup avec les noirs
pour le P5 surtout ça fait
peur on verra ça doit être nul mais je
pense va se délecter de cette ligne en
je crois qu'il adore jouer les trucs
sans risque mais tu sais que moi j'avais
un peu ce truc aussi j'adorais quoi tu
te délectes bah parce que j'aime bien
jouer longtemps sans
risque moins qu'avant maintenant mais
la chaîne facile qui a dépassé les
200000 abonnés j'ai vu ton tweet c'est
beau bientôt devant la chaîne principale
alors je pense dans de semaines ou
exordinaire comment tuexliqu succès bah
est facile
quoi par au million non mais c'est quand
même et ça a tout échangé vraiment
facile quoi com que c'est le but mais ça
fait tell de gens so plus en mode facile
qu'en mode tiens un petit peu plus
loinin plus tu es bas plus a de monde en
fait comme dans tout la base de la
pyramide donc c'est la don on vous parla
B je sais pas si mais on imagine c'est
un coup logique aussi penser à faire
tour des
peut-être plus
fort
on va att voir cette F on va se délecter
à mon avis
là
ça
réfléchi on est beaucoup à être éclaté
au jeu ouais c'est pas
faux pas on n pas le même niveau mais on
a la même passion ça c'est beau bon je
prendrais quand même au 4 à sa place
hein mais il fait pas il fait fou des
deux après il vaut mieux être éclaté et
pas aigri quoi nous des fois on est un
peu aigri du jeu
quoi aux yeux d'enfants
non des fois je vois des des amateurs
quoi il vois des des des trucs tactiques
des machins ils sont hyper heureux je W
mais c'est génial en fait au contraire
vous pouvez encore vous émerveiller
euh de ce beau
jeu
nous malheureusement on a un peu déjà
tout vu quoi
ouais truc c'est qu'on a quasiment ENF
on pas vu toutes lesons tactiques
possibles mais on en a vu une quantité
quand même ouis les parties
célèbresatta les trucs et
celle Fab m'a éclaté à l' de tu t'as
peut-être Laté euh
ouais pourant j'avais pas très bien joué
à ce tourno si c'est ça être un mec dans
les premiè rond complètement explosé
sûement il y a un peu plus d'ailleurs je
pense j'habita encore à Montpellier je v
partir en 2011 de là-bas mais
ouais c'est un nor ko non ce
t on peut être éclaté et gris aussi on
peut être éclaté tu es gris ouis mais
bon é gris je sais pas je crois pas qu'
so mais je crois pas
non oui qu'on soit pe-être un peu
exigeant et qu'on a moins des yeux ébis
surtout probablement mais c'est pas non
plus très gris
quoita pas émervill hier devant ce mvel
Naka MV Naka fait
plaisir bah on a tellement été
émerveillé qu'on l' qu'on a qu Mme
analyser il fait une vidéo dessus
hein mais après je sais pas à quel point
blaser ou pas enfin ça'empêche pas que
genre on fait ce qu'on veut pour
partager le nombre de vidéos que tu as
fait ta chaîne je sais pas on fait les
livres dans les livres on essaie de
parler de trucs qu'on trouve beau et
joli sur les combinaisons des anecdotes
des parties célèbres non non en en
vérité le seul souci des échecs s'il
peut y en avoir un c'est la scène haut
niveau qui est c'est la pire scène au
niveau de tous les sports que je regarde
et que je connaisse c'est la scène au
niveau la moins intéressante
ouais mais bon ça vient aussi peut-être
de l'organisation du ah ça vient à 100 %
des des organisations c'est sûr mais
pour moi la la scène au niveau qui
pourrait être géniale elle est
cataclysmique genre j'ai pas image d' un
peu tout quoi ouais mais j'ai pas image
d'un sport qui soit aussi inintéressant
à suivre pour le haut niveau
ouais je sais pas trop oui oui non ben
c'est pas ouais je crois que c'est
vraiment donc ENIT c'est pas égris des
échecs mais oui la scène haut niveau
clairement euh mais après a raison enfin
c'est vraiment nul oui oui oui c'est pas
en fait ouais j'ai l'imession qu'on
essaie d'être objectif sérieusement et
si c'est bien on dit et si c'est pas
bien et malheureusement c'est souvent le
cas bon on dit aussi quoi on n'est pas
là à faire wouah génial tout tout le
temps et et apprendre les gens pour des
idiots si on joue bien B on est on est
content cette fois j'ai bien joué si on
joue mal et ça arrive malheureusement
plus souvent bah ok j'ai pas bien joué
j'ai pas bien joué quoi enfin ou même
c'est pas trop d' d'intérêt je vous
montre pas quoi parce que quoi quoi
montrer et et voilà mais bon évidemment
on peut on peut profiter aussi de la
crédulité des gens et toujours en
rajouter et G gnna
mais il fait damass 7 en tout cas alors
peut-être faut prendre 4 et faut prendre
B4
prend3 prend C5 et B C5 bouff F3 mais
par contre en fa comme la 7 c'est ça que
ça change c'est que si tu prends B4 je
pensais faire d prend4 mais tu prends
quoi donc non pas assez bien ce que je
raconte après tout le monde dit ça de sa
scène qu' en connait un peu les
coulisses ouais non mais les échecsousen
c'est quand même mais oui tu as aussi
raison enfin mais je crois queon a quand
même atteint non non mais il a raison s
les échecs on a atteint un truc on a
raison aussi mais tout le monde a raison
quoi c'est vrai ce que tu dis mais juste
les échecs je crois qu'on
a ce que je vois je vois pour les
eSports enfin certains je parle de ceux
qui sont populaires qume un jeu
populaire je parle pas des trucs
complètement à côté mais mais ils
réussissent quand même à faire des trucs
sympas de temps en temps ils ont des
grands événements sympas au long de
l'année tuas tu as des trucs qui sont
naz et tu as quelques trucs sympas le
problème aux échecs c'est qu'on a rien
de
sympa je tombé sur l'équipe de la finale
de championnat du monde d'Excel c'est
plus entertain que les candidats mais ça
m'étonne pas c'est quoi Excel Excel ch
logiciel champion du monde bah peut-être
faut taper hyper vite des trucs hein
faire des tableurs à fond calculer des
colonnes faire les additions et tout non
mais moi je suis sûr à 100 % que le
public ça change tout les fléchettes au
niveau pas très patient plus c'est
fantastique les fléchettes mais là je
suis hyper heureux moi je v Allis voir
les les demi-finales du championnat du
monde mais tu sais que j'ai voulu le
faire une année j'ai un problème de visa
avec Len mais c'est je suis hyper
heureux je acheter mes places mon billet
d'avion et
compagnie j'ai fait pas ça pour les
échecs en fait non non intérant bah
ouais mais enfin tu vois ENF je mes
premiers degrés là enfin c'est pas une
connerie j'y vais vraiment et moi je
suis pas
[Musique]
plus j'ai envie d'aller déguiser dans le
public être en crocodile ou je sais pas
quoi et avoir mes mes trucs
enfin il éche classiqu était passionnant
avant le module c'est vrai aussi hein
que pour moi l'ordi a pas fait du bien
au jeu ou alors ce qui a pas fait du
bien c'est de pas être arrivé à
s'adapter et avoir cru qu'on gardait le
même modèle et que
ce moi je pense que ça c'est pas que ça
va fait du bien c'est qu'en fait c'est
un truc auquel tu es obligé de t'adapter
parce que c'est un trop gros tu peux
rien y faire il est là il est l'ordiain
c'est comme quand les mecs ont découvert
le feu et puis toi tu je ne vais pas
luutiliser bon bah enfin tu oui enfin de
froid puis voilà ouis mais tu dois
t'adap c'est un trop gros changement
pour ne pas s'y adapter c'est pas l'ordi
qui a fait du mal c'est la bêtise
humaine non mais l'ordi après c'est un
peu chiant c'est vrai que bon quand ils
font des conneries on le voit instant
parce que le truc monte descend alors
que bon avant il fallait quand même
dissquer les parties euh mais la nature
du jeu a changé parce que il y a
tellement de théories maintenant il faut
tout apprendre et c'est chiant mais du
coup pourquoi pas plus de 960 et cetera
quoi
mais mais du coup ça a modifié un peu le
jeu ça a modifié la perception ça
modifié aussi le respect du public parce
que autant avant il pouvait pas
comprendre maintenant il branche le modu
dire bah il est nul c'est un con bon oui
enfin il est pas si con on comprend
pourquoi il a fait une connerie il se
trouve que oui il a fait une connerie
mais bah d'ailleurs nous aussi au bout
d'un moment ouais mais en fait on le dit
pas à chaque fois on le fait si on pense
que c'était vraiment évitable après bon
on peut se tromper hein mais
mais c'est pas chaque erreur ma fait B5
qui é consid comme doute par l'ordi
intéressant pas chaque coup à chaque
fois après oui quand tu 3 ou quoi
bon dire bravo par 3 quand
Mme mais donc je sais pas l'ORD a changé
la perception du jeu la manière de jouer
moi je trouve ça plus chiant a peut-être
d trouver autre chose pour adapter
après je me répète pour la 10è fois
aujourd'hui mais pour moi un sport sans
public c'est
inregardable quel qu'il soit tennis tu
enlève le public je pense que tu on
regarde plus foot enlèv le tennis tu
regardes plus le foot le public tu
regardes plus j'en suis convaincu les
fléchettes sans public c'est évident que
c'est inintéressant possible je dois
dire en fait le foot enfin on a eu le
cas de figure donc tuavais rappelé
parfois que pendant le covid il mettait
du du faux public en band son pour ah
bah ou pour que tu viv mais en fait moi
je me rends compte quand je vais dans
des resto bar qui te monre quand même le
match mais mettre leur musique à la con
euh pour pas casser l'ambiance du du
l'endroit et que tu as le foot sans son
euh c'est naz c'est je regarde quand
même j'ai envie de savoir le score mais
j'aimerais pas le faire souvent j'ai
envie d'aller dans un endroit qui me met
le foot le son les commentaires à la
rigueur et au pire juste son ambiance de
stade mais ah mais moi je suis convaincu
que le sport sans ambiance quel qu'il
soit même les sports les plus populaires
du monde demain le foot tu enlèves le
son tu tu tu montres que les joueurs je
suis sû que le sport devient lambda dans
2 ans ouais tu forces tous les stades à
H clos pendant 2 ans et tu tu trouves
rien
pour en tu dis voais le sport va être à
8 clos à vitamternam enfin c'est la
nouvelle pas comme le covid quoi mais
c'est c'est mainant c'est comme ça ouais
non mais MS su sûr que dans 2 ans il y a
plus de foot peut-être faut que les
joueurs puissent bien s'entendre sur le
terrain et bien concentré avant de tirer
quoi donc pareil le tennis tu tu mets
tous les tournois à 8 cl à vitamum tu
c'est un sport on a plus le droit de
venir regarder je suis sûr que c'est le
sport est terminé en 2 ans mais pendant
le covid la différence du covid c'est
que c'était tout comme ça donc tu avais
pas de comparatif mais c'était pas bien
pendant le covid juste ils ont fait
parce que ils voulaient pas s'arrêter
complètement et et détruire les sportifs
parce qu'il ne jouent pas pendant un an
2 ans et puis on saait pas combien de
temps ça allait durer donc à un moment
tu te dis bon bah on va s'adapter on
fait ce qu'on peut euh après peut-être
qu'on était pas obligé de le faire enfin
bon après c'était décidé à des niveaux
dessus donc donc peu importe mais
euh mais mais c'était pas si mal de
laisser les gens on pratiqué leur leur
sport et bah du coup ils trouvaient ça
risqué qu'il y a du monde bon bah ils
ont fait sans sans public sans non mais
comme c'est tous les sports qui le fais
en même temps du coup tu ça faait pas
bizarre ENF c'était bizarre mais tout
était bizarre donc céit pas un sport en
particulier qui était ils ont trouvé des
subterfuges aussi ouais il mettaient du
faux
son
ouais comme dit nepka le son de manière
générale c'est super important en terme
d'expérience immersive mais je crois que
c'est vraiment ça ça fait partie de nous
en tant qu'humain
profondément POS une question
intéressante ce problème de public là
depuis quand sur mon à 50 en arrière
est-ce qu'il y avait ce même problème le
truc c'est que là en fait on a aussi le
problème que maintenant euh pour
populariser et diffuser c'est différent
de juste organiser un événement et
personne en parle fait que des gens
jouent ENF comme moi en fait quand je
joue au tennis j'ai zéro public et je
joue mon match tout seul je m'en fous en
fait du public je préfère pasutiliser en
public quoi donc je suis très content de
jouer tout seul mais en tant que
spectateur si je suis devant ma télé ou
quoi j'ai envie qu' a cette
ambiance a du public non non j'ai jamais
vu du public non tu as le droit d'y
aller non mais tu droit d'y aller j'avis
vu des gens assis
chantter j'ai jamais vu en
fait
attention quand même qu' il se prend
petite pression là tout d'un
coup le par Ron qui parle du
conservatisme des échecs bah en fait oui
et non il rouson parce qu'en réalité les
échec c'était un un jeu de barre de base
euh quand même qui était
régence et en fait ils sont inventé un
conservative mais qui est pas enfin ils
ont inventé une époque où ils ont figé
le temps et ils sont conservateur d'un
truc précis mais ils sont pas
conservateur du jeu parce qu'en réalité
les ambiances cool de je aux échecs
machin des bars et cetera
[Musique]
c'est c'était plutôt un jeu convivial
marrant où les
G ah oui tu proposé ce coup mais non en
fait c'était en fait ils sont
conservateurs mais d'un d'un truc qui se
sont autoinenté quoi son conservateur
des échècs de B vinique quoi c'est ça
ouais son conservateur des échècs de B
vinque ouais en gros mais ils sont pas
conservateurs d'un truc
ancien moi je suis sur elle avec les
blancsin pas l'air simple la position à
défendre je complètement avec les blanc
je sais même pas quoi jouer en fait
alors qu'il peut avoir un pion de plus
ouais je sais pas trop ça enfin je vois
je regarde hein je vois que ça a tourner
mais je sais pas il a pas pris le pion
une fois deux fois et mais il l'a jamais
pris il l' jamais pris
ouais prise prise d' pr ouais c'est
peut-être ce que je fa d' prend mais bon
d' pr de r
H3 je suis pas forcément d'accord tu
peux apprécier le sport sans public si
tu connais des choses intéressantes ce
dernier stratégie technique je pense
vraiment à le foot tu enlèves le son de
toutes les des des diffusions des son du
stade et tu fais des h clos je suis
convaincu que le sport est pas super
intéressant à regarder non mais enfin
moi ça m'arrive en fait de regarder par
sur mon téléphone quand je peux pas et
je mets pas de son parce que voilà je
regarde le match en fait j'ai envie de
savoir le score je suis pris par bon moi
j'aime bien voir Sainté c'est moche mais
mais si c'était que ça le foot depuis
toujours j'aurais pas enfin en fait le
truc je fais ça quand je suis forcé mais
j'aimerais pas faire ça tout le temps
peut-être un moment ça me dégoûterait
bon ça me saoule je regarde pas parce
que je peux pas dire je prend un plaisir
fou en fait je le fais parce que j'ai
envie d'être au courant et oui mais en
fait si tu avais que eu cette expérience
là qu' avait jamais eu personne dans les
stad que les stad avent jamais existé tu
serais même jamais devenu supporter de
la SS tu aurais m jamais regardé le truc
non non mais je pense le foot en plus
sautoalimente de ce parce que des fois
tu vois des bars qui débordent des gens
dans la rue qui sont heureux enfin ça
donne envie de participer je pense que
tout déborde en fait de ça genre moi je
me rappelle le tennis même avec Vlad on
avait regardé alors que Vlad il est pas
trop trop tennis enfin il est tennis
mais à l'ancienne et il s retrouvé à
regarder la finale Jo féerer mais parce
que c'était wibleon parce que il se
passe de la folie ouaisou
il se passe complètement de la folie
mais c'est chaud là
ou je comprends mais ouais en au début
je pensaisétait du mis
quoi qui intéressant ce ce qu'il font et
l'un et l'autre fait tour
des5 sur tour pr il y a tour des mat et
surore F hein tu me diras mais
bon le fait que sil faut fit ça don
envie mais bon il y a dam B4 j'imagine
c'est pas facile t
[Musique]
des bon peut-être il va prendre F7
prendre F7 sur4 faire t
F5 so F bar on prend5 so t C4 qui
va5 t je pas c ou quoi mais
encore
s va nous embêter on va prendre B5 on
doit tenir la nulle mais plutôt en étant
du mauvais côté mais c'est ce qu'il fait
en fait t C4 je
pense CER D5 cavalier E5 cavalier
D7 pensis mais fou G1 tu vois calier E5
tour C2 calier D7 G1 ça je regarde tu
prends B5 tu prends H2 je monte en G4 on
va faire nul mais jeen ai ouais tu vas
être mieux mais bon oui on va faire nul
donc tu peux pas retirer les
commentaires de n'importe quel sport le
storying ça change moi je parle pas des
commentaires c'est je dis même tu gardes
les commentaires du sport mais tu
enlèves le public le sport meurt enin
Meur il comme les gens disent il y aura
encore des fans oui mais genre le foot
c'est plus le sport numéro 1 au monde si
tu si si tu fais du wi ad 4 mais
peut-être qu'il meurt avec le temps
c'estàd Queen fait la génération qui a
connu va continuue regarder jusqu'à la
fin mais que tes enfants vont vont dire
qu'est-ce tu regardes comme il va il va
il va vivre que sur le sur son acquis
sur le souvenir c'est qu'il a tellement
d'acquis que oui mais en fait et et là
c'est en acquis mais si avait jamais eu
une seule personne qui avait eu le droit
de rentrer dans un stade pour supporter
une équipe en fait ça aurait même jamais
existé ouais et et du coup ça va mourir
à terme parce que les gens qui
connaissaient les Akis à un moment ils
seront plus là malheureusement
et il y aura des nouveaux qui voilà
la sal analise est blindée sans
personnes tassé déjà c'est peu sans
personnes et ils vendent combien le
billet non mais ch V c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt un truc non mais je
sais que c'est rien enfin pour le coup
sans personne c'est même pas district de
foot mais non mais c'est sans personnees
dans un truc où tu as réuni des milliers
de personnes qui jouent aux échecs c'est
rien en fait mais en soi c'est mieux que
ce qu'il font en général dans les t on a
d'échecs quoi je dis pas l'inverse mais
c'est rien mais oui il faut pas se
penser que c'est oui je suis
d'accord bon ça va faire nul mais bon il
va quand même essayer Abd mais oui le
cavalier est très bien pour défendre sur
une aile il y a que deion contre
un des échecs c'est super pour tous les
goûts ouais ouais mais c'est enfin ça
fonctionne pas en tout cas ça que soit
super je suis d'accord avec toi mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça fonctionne pas
du
tout on peut pas le
nier qu'on soit pas d'accord sur comment
régler le problème ça je peux
l'entendre mais le fait qu' enfin sur le
diagnostic en fait qu' a rien qui aille
ça c'est c'est juste un fait c'est même
pas discutable après comment régler le
problème
ouais bah V fais les payer 30 € la place
on verra si c'est siil y a du monde en
fait parce que gratuit ça compte pas
quoi
enfin spectateur gratuit sans spectateur
gratuit c'est c'est rien quoi c'est
c'est zéro
oui genre le Paris Football Club a mis
les places gratuites au stade là ils
avaient 2 3000 personnes en général ils
sont à
8000 non puis bon c'était dans un
tournoi d'échec donc tu as réuni une
énorme population de gens qui jouent et
donc ça crée un B assez énorme si le
débat assez bête un sport sans
spectateur et moins regarder logique les
sport populairire le son car ils sont
populaires non enfin les échecs pe par
nature il ils mettent pas de spectateur
donc non c'est pas bête en fait contre
exemple le poker tu as pas de spectateur
et pourtant le
showambiance mais il y a une ambiance au
poker une ambiance les mecs se parlent
machin en plus c'est vraiment
particulier le poker pour le coup et
puis c'est pas si populaire que ça à
vrai
dire puis tu as l'argent
tuas
de l'ambiance ou pas les échecs c'est
pas excitant longue ou rapide bah en
fait je suis pas d'accord
mais il va peut-être la gagner en fait
se retrouve très très mal et ouais mais
il va la gagner en
fait c'est fou ça mais W c'est fou ce
qu'il a
fait c'était pas si enfin c'était très
simple mais non mais la finale était pas
si facile facile avec peu de temps mais
ce qui est fou c'est toutes ces
décisions quand il a pas pris le pion en
plus ouais ça c'était
fou après il s'est fait retourner
finalement mais bon je dois dire que sur
l'ensemble des trois parties ce serait
pas si logique soit devant bon il aura
pu avoir un demi aussi hein mais joue le
gar toutes les games s' y en a un qui
doit mener c'est plutôt c'est plutôt Abd
ouais il pousse hein H4 en plus il y a
pas qu' F6 là c'est cool ouais c'est ça
du coup avance
quoi
ça on ça fondin
ouais j'uris faire G2 mais c'est pareil
il veut G3 G2 et ouais mais c'est ça
tourné comment c'était tout d'un coup ça
allit puis ben je sais pas en fait là il
s son G4 là déjà c'est bizarre je pense
avec les
Blancs il voulait ouais en fait il
voulait peut-être sur avec du cavalier
F5 mais bah c'est le coupér de l'ordi
j'avais pas vu et moi j'avais dans
l'idée en fait j'ai vu ça je voulais H5
pu on prend t F4 ouais ça OK ou même ro
point F5 d'ailleurs mais
enfin7 et du coup là si j tu tu par ro
F6 pour éviter moi je pensais que tu
pouvais faire même du KG3 mais F4 mais
là tu peux bouffer tu bouffes ouais donc
en fait il aurait su avec cavalier F5 je
crois que c'était nul ouais ouais mais
il a pas fait mais c'est bizarre parce
que c'est la Seu idée de
G4 bon ça mais là en fait du coup il su
un peu il se dit ah merde si je
là il il se barre à contens avec le
cavalier enfin ça va pas du tout mais
pourquoi il attends juste pour savoir
enfin ouais ouais ouais F5
on non non mais oui c'est pour ça enfin
je pensais tour à 6 alors c'était pas si
con com il a fait remonte retour échec
ouais non mais ouais pour avir F5
en
en échange mais bon après peu de temps
il ça fait pe
biz gag je
cro
en fait c'est fou parce que les il y a
21 mais ça pourrait être 3-0 dans les
deux matchs JEE les parti
donc les deux premiers finalement de la
phasebit déboité
ou ok intéressant ben peut-être victoire
abdana dans ce on va voir on vous dit à
tout de
[Musique]
suite now with the offal col from
Chess.com Mount them ins with magnet kit
and swap themever you like make your get
an exclusive discount on all metals shop
now with the code
[Musique]
displate.com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est reparti c'est mesames et
messieurs qui reje la per comme contre
Maxime et il a bien
raison même même ligne contre Maxim F
mais plus plus classique
petit
faire6
àes questions l'autre jour nous étions
questionn il fait
làdessus
vades
ça bien qu' fonctionner contre
Maxime en fait il était pas bien mais il
a fini par
gagner il était vraiment pas bien
non bonus les blancs peuvent faire 4
bien sûr en général pour éviter B5 ou
fou F4 fou
G5 développement du
Fou donc match nul gagnerit le 7 hein
pour j'aille me moucher va donc va
donc donc H6 FO H4 4 et VO là qui va
réfléchir comment agancer ses pièces en
gros il a envie de faire la poussée E5
s'il peut donc peut-être jouer un coup
comme dame C7 on peut penser à Dame à 5
qui BD7 c'est pourrait aider mais après
faut se demander qu'est-ce que je fais
si les blancs font E5 eux même parce que
je me suis pris la case de retrait et
cetera mais en gros les Noirs ils
aimeraient jouer au 5 et stabiliser le
centre ainsi et et voir ensuite comment
ça se passe mais déjà commencer par
ça
après je sais pas peut-être que Wesley
se tat à jouer G5 d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu' vient de faire pour aller peut-être
prendre ce fou et du coup déséquilibrer
la
partie bah
directement donc intéressant s'il prend
ce fou évidemment il s'est un petit peu
affaibli les cases autour du roi mais
bon il aura la paire de fou il pourra
col maté bah après voir si jou avec E5
avec e 6 F5 avec D5 avec C5 un joueur
avec B5 enfin en fait la pire que
l'intérêt c'est que on n'a pas défini la
structure de P au centre et on peut
s'adapter à ce que fait l'adversaire et
voir selon les enjeux euh là j'aurais
l'impression que si jamais je venit
apprendre h pr j' dirais bien pour du E6
F5 parce que ça Colm tras pas mal ça ça
pourrait ouvrir un peu le jeu pour les
fous et cetera
oui jepris et donc à noter hein qu'il y
a pas de découverte sur cavalier H5 pour
l'instant puisque celui-là a nulle part
trop où aller s'il prend G5 il y aura
qu' prend G3 d'abord et on pour
reprendre ensuite en G5 c'est le genre
de variante qui pourrait marcher si les
Blancs avaient par un P E3 une dame en
C2 ou en D3 sur quoi qui G5 serait fort
puisquil y aurait une menace de mat en
H7 et le cavaler attaquer mais pas pas
ici bref il a fait A4 donc un coup qui
vise à empêcher un futur B5 et westle
qui peut donc venir prendre le fou mais
en même temps il y a pas il y a pas
urgence puisque le fou a nulle part où
aller donc il joue un peu ce qu'il veut
il pourrait se développer il pourrait
bah peut-être faire le fameux6 pour
prendre et suivre par F5 il pourrait je
sais pas Dom C7 peut-être euh des coups
comme ça il a un peu l'air d'avoir le
seum Wesley
ouais bon match difficile hein pas il a
fait à 5 il empêche son adversaire
d'avancer de prendre plus d'espace il
veut peut-être jouer avec des cavalier
A6 qui B4 à un moment on
verra et attention ce n'est pas un
Armagedon là c'est juste une part la 4è
manche du match le premier à 2 et demi
gagne al pas le match mais le 7 en fait
on aurait dû
modifier le mini le match d'aujourd'hui
qu on pourrait dire ça comme ça le mini
match 1
7 mais je trouve cette ouverture elle
est vraiment pas mal pour jouer le gain
P bah ouais c'est très bien genre mieux
que noralement il y a beaucoup qui
faisaient la méthode ruise je trouve
c'est plus éic ça bah c'est moins bon
heinise mais c'est jamais facile avec
les Blancs quand même de faire nul non
non mais en fait il
fauton faut jouer normalement et puis
quand tu peux faire nul tu fais nul
parce que tu as l'occasion quoi mais
mais M gen autant en longue l'imession
qu'ils font nul un peu comme ils veulent
ouais mais c'est même jamais si en fait
du coup peut-être contre la pireas juste
jouer normal tant pis mais j'ai
l'impression tu jou tu joues ton
attaqueen tram des de ou peu importe
l'imession que les trucs là qu'il font
pour jouer pour faire nul c'est ça
devient vite plus facile à jouer pour
les Noirs non mais c'est pas simple en
fait moi j'aime bien jouer la per que en
Open ou quoi dans les premières rondes
parce que ça offre ça offre des
positions où tu peux jouer pour le gain
quoi to tu es un bon joueur de PIR en
plus non j'aime bien j'aime bien je
m'étais mis à la jouer depuis
2013 j'avais pensé depuis longue date en
fait corporement répertoire un jouur des
indien mais al c'est quand même pas les
mêmes enjeux mais tiens ça ressemble un
peu et de deux ben pour pour jouer le
gain pas juste faire des françaises ou
quoi
ou des sicilienes et j'avais bien aimé
un livre de de moscalenko dessus qui m'a
mis le
piedétrier je sais plus comment il
l'avait appelé de Perfect Pirk moderne
je
crois alors c'est pas un livre
particulièrement d'ouverture d'ouverture
ou il t'analyse tout en détail il te
fait un peu par chapitre selon les setup
des blancs gen celi-là un autre il te
montre un peu les plans
possibles les pièges les quelques
parties modèles et puis voilà la fameuse
partie de Vlad
contre bariefief non le double sacrifice
de qualité qui est dans le Livre bleu
d'ailleurs prog bon mais par bar aussi
qu'il aime bien s' n'y a ni l'une ni
l'autre non non mais apprendre à jouer
la pire non ça pour le coup je
recommande unel
recommande c'est pour dire mais pour le
coup je même plus que un autre livre qui
fait un plus grand travail d'ouverture
serit genre the tiger
modne il personne grand Suédois qui qui
l' écrit qui qui qui jouit souvent avec
la moderne ave A6 B5 ou même marine qui
écrit grand maîre répertoire ou quoi
mais ça c'est que théorie théorie
théorie théor ouais c'est
c'est après chacun son goû hein mais
j'avais préféré ouais ce truc de de
mosqueenko qui au moins tu captes ce qui
se passe après tu fais tes propres
recherches et cetera puis voilà mais je
vois ce qui est intéressant c'est que là
on est à 11 ce coup il fait exactement
le truc de vouloir éviter la théorie de
un truc pour faire nul et c'est déjà
mieux au noir objectivement
ouais alors je sais pas si c'est
vraiment mieux mais en tout cas c'est
sûr que c'est pas moins bien et que tu
as une partie
tu as plus qu'une partie ouais peut-être
tu es mieux d' mais donc les blancs il
oui il vaut mieux rentrer dans l'AR que
faire
ça en rapide en tout
cas
est-ce qu'on switch entre les deux
parties non mais tu peux aller voir le
live en anglais je crois qu'ils sont
plus sur la partie de de Carlsen caroana
nous Carlsen carwana on a beaucoup vu
déjà on est intéressé avec Fab de voir
un peu d'autres joueurs d'autres joueurs
et puis surtout que a quand même gagné
le la la Phe de Calif et abdous il était
champion du du monde il y a 2 ans donc
c'est c'est une belle opposition de
joueurs qu'on a pas vu jouer l'un contre
l'autre et finalement jusqu'à maintenant
il y a eu trois
victoires c'est animé c'est sympa mais
bon enfin ça se défond aussi de voir
Magnus contreo évidemment oui mais après
comme si il est plus regardé sur le live
officiel comme ça vous avez vraiment le
choix on est parti sur ce match
peut-être jur un peu moins connu mais je
trouve que laaffiche est hyper sympa
c'est nouvelle génération enfin il y a
pas mal de choses
quoi
g feed pour la Calif au candidat ça
pourrait se jouer à pilou
face c'est très
beau Dominguez qui a fait nul d'ailleurs
ça semble laisser un boulevard
à après
faudra c'est d'aller jouer des
openit
je suisoujour
motivé il va avoir peut-être une partie
plus facile demain avec les Blancs ouais
benah je j'imagine bien qu'aujourd'hui
il a eu les blancs il aur sûrement battu
son adversaire c'est un joueur américain
je sais pas MRE Fed à 2380 mais je
connais pas al ça trouve il est jeune pe
peut-être qu'il a 16 ans
que
il faut quoi il
faut de trois victoires pour récupérer
les points qu'il perd
aujourd'hui contre il doit perdre 4 et
demi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui donc je sais pas trop mais
ouais ouais c'est c'est dur enfin mon
avis il va y laisser des plumes domingas
dans ce tournoi de toute façon avant
même que ça commence c'éit mon avis
mais en tout cas bon il tente il tente
hein voilà il a raison cé une chance
sement inespérit pour lui il se
représentera peut-être pas si tôt il a
déjà 40 ans il se représentera peut-être
jamais en fait ou donc donc il va jouer
ce tournoi bah il savait que ça serait
pas facile parce que bah c'est en mode
open il doit il do il doit faire le
voyage avec le décalage horaire et
cetera et cetera donc al je vais je je
vais regarder je vais regarder combien
il a perdu de point et l' tiens
Dominguez fait on peut le voir sur 27
schez ah ouais il a perdu
cher
4,2 c'est
d B6 jouer Fab ce qui est pas mal une
petite pression sur le P B2 sur le P D4
aussi mais la dame en jeu et la dame
sera pas en danger ici donc c'est c'est
plutôt pas mal parfois elle pourra même
venir en
b4on comment ça se passe et comme d'ab
on peut préparer cl noir bah soit E5
soit C5 soit peut-être même des E6 D5
selon comment ça
profil alors E5 on aime bien en général
le pion G6 un P
G5 faut quand même regarder à deux fois
ça fait un énorme trou en F5 donc ça
j'aime jamais trop mais après à voir si
les pièces Blanes je peux aller dessus
en général c'est les cavaliers qui
aiment bien et ils aur des passages
genre VI D13
F5
donc le 5 à mon avis serait pas trop ce
que je ferais moi j'ai envie de mettre
un pion avec en tout cas pour couvrir et
après j'avise si je fais C5 je fais D5
si je fais rien je reste je mon ro je
fais F5 à
voir
cette paire de fou c'est quand même un
vrai avantage à long terme ouais Ahou
bien sûr puis là bon bien sûr dame B6
comme disait donc ça attaque B2
directement mais ça fait pression sur D4
et on peut commencer à penser à G4
chasse le cavalier F3 pour les prendre
des4 c'est directement des
menaces
est qu'on peur d' prend B2 VO là c'est
une menace quand même ouais bah en fait
oui enfin si tu peux enfermer la dame tu
as pas peur sinon ben tu perds juste un
pion et
sient ce que tu joues tu peux l'empêcher
quand même enfin je tu peux rendre dame
prend B2 oui ben genre si tu fais dam D3
par
exemple mais donc dame D3 je me
questionne qu'est-ce qui se passe sur G4
ça rcupérer ouais d prend D4 calitre F5
prend D3 qui est PR7 TR Bou prise D3
ouais mais F5 on peut aussi ramener la
dame en F6 là
mais bon il joue agressif ok bah il a
pas tort
peut-être ouais mais je trouve qu'il
joue à contresens oui il aura dû jouer
agressif avant mais là en fait c'est il
joue agressif de mur fait ou mais
c'était pas son choix
Dom fait n aussi
ou ça
faiblesse score avec les Blancs c'est
pas
trop
marrant quand même ces
joueurs qui tout d'un coup ont du mal à
faire avec les Blancs alors que
d'habitude c'est quand même ils ont un
tau de réussite quand même assez ouais
élev aura peut-être un armaged en tout
cas on l'espère ce serait tellement
tellement dommage Fab ou de déjàer se
coucher déjà aller se coucher à 21h30
21h40 et là c'est bien erreur
apparemment
ça se voit en fait que c'est nettement
mieux pour les noir ça l' juste normal
on développe la dernière pièce qui une
action centrale tu ramener la tour et
ouais blan qui font dans les deux
parties on peut retrouver le sourire
ah
enfin on a eu peur de pas les avoir
aujourdhu arm et là on reprend confiance
est-ce qu'on est bien sûr qu'il des aRM
a de de moait des armes jeéfier je te
crois je suis au courant de rien donc je
me questionne ça m'étonnerait qu'il
mettent pas d'armagadon ce serait
dommage je vérifie mais pour moi il a
des armagadons tout le
tempsin tu vois j'en aurais pas mis moi
je sais bon j'ai des idées bizarres mais
ouais parce que toi tu es con ouais oui
benah oui
ah bon tu aurais fait une erreur de
débutant quoi tu aurais pas mis
l'armagon bon ok tu es complètement à
côté
Fab je suis en train de de pêcher l'info
mais pour moi il y aaganon en cas de nul
de de match nul je vois pas pour il
aurait pas mis en fait c'est tellement
délectant
serait dommage quand même des enchères
toujours comme d'hab
vraiment j'espère en tout
cas
bon un coup
DESC mais
peut-être Jer les blanc mais
bon une
colonne aussi noir
peêtre vraiment faire F demand non mais
pourquoi pas en fait qu' en
l'air
et aussi F5 c'est que je pensais
après on espère qu'il trouve évidemment
pouran alors as-tu eu la confirmation
j'ai pas la confirmation mais en fait
j'en suis sûr tuas l'intime
conviction je vois un peu comment ils
font leur format s'il se pose la
question mais est-ce qu'on Armon ou pas
en fait ou évidemment c'est une petite
variante pour le chat dame prend B2 dame
prend C5 dame prend C3 il a F prend F7
dommage parce que pas
loin bon c'est qu' aéfléchi en tout
cas il
fait prendre C2 il fait coup moi qui m'a
pas l'air
mauvais pas pas juste parce que
tu la finale
non
jouer est-ce qu'on se dé de l'autre
côté en train de revenir un peu dans la
partie là
mais Mo il va pas
trouver
bah tu as peut-être pas trop le choix en
fait parce que çaasse B4 et de gagner
une pièce attends il a plein de coup de
l'autre côté fa on n pas le temps de
tout voir voir fa qu'on retourne quand
même bah tiens c'est exactement Laon VI
de dire ça para c'est tellement sûr que
ça allait jouer
ça
ça se rapproche un peu de nul serait
tellement tellement tellement tellement
dommage
Fab côté d' qui n t les bras
oui arm pour chaque 7 j'ai la
confirmation
Fab
donc on est nous on a vraiment besoin
d'une victoire de Wesley et de Magnus
pour bien se déctter
ensuite non je dire pourquoi moi je je
nurais pas mis oui fait je pense que
j'aurais mis un Armon à la fin du 3è set
cétait pas départagé là tu as une manche
une bon vous faites la Manche une et une
manche 2ur il a gagné il nul il nul on
fait TR fait encore nul Gon parce queut
finir je pensais que d'avoir deux
manches distinctes c déjà une sorte de
départage de l'une de l'autre
quoi alors que pas du tout en
fait je comprends ce que tu veux dire
ouais en fait je veux dire c'est pas
vital qu'on a un vainqueur
aujourd'hui il arrivera demain le
vainqueur de toute façon je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable
oui ça rajoute de l'ye d'avoir
l'armagadon ouais on est bien sûr ouais
bah oui ça fait une partie de plus plus
ça dure longtemps mieux c'est Fab non
c'est qu' les enchères c'est
que je suis fait l'avocat du diable non
mais tuas bien
raison tu prends
non
pas tant que
ça pas mal jouer de la part dele ce coup
C5 inattendu que mais le P prise de
manières différentes mais sur et l'un et
l'autre il peut
récupérer il je pas mal ouais c'est là
quand
même non il joue pas mal juste il est
pas aller chercher C de mais peut-être
qu'il a raison parce que on sait pas
trop enfin on voit que ça aura pu
attaquer côté blanc mais bon mais il
préfère bon il est fidè à son style on
va dire on j comme ça l'autre avantage
de l'armagedon pour me refaire l'avocat
du diable c'est imagine tu gagnes le
premier set tu gagnes le premier bon peu
importe le score ouais 2è set tu fais
match nul il y a 22 tu la vis bah là en
fait bah non bah là au moins il y a un
armagadon ça t'empêche de fermer la vis
oui mais bon comme d'hab tu as gagné le
droit de fermer la V parce que tu as
gagné le premier set ouais mais ça a
fait baisser l'ype
ouais enfin bien sûr mais elle aurait
été sur la 4e partie où il y en avait un
qui était obligé de gagner ou to figure
tu as gagné le premier set toujours tu
mènes 21 dans le deème set ouais là
normalement le match bah là non parce
que si tu gagnes tuégalises et il a
magadon donc voilà mais oui mais donc ça
fera plus de parties mais bon à un
moment je pense là tu mérites de gagner
quoi mais fait B
non mais d'ailleurs c'est pas très
normal quoi une victoireagedon vaille
autant qu'une victoire 3-0
Flam si gagne bah il va avoir un
armagadon mais par exemple si il y a de
de et gag deè set et a 2 dans le deè set
c'est Abdou qui le
regagne l'utre Armagedon bah du coup ENF
vous avez
compris
tout ça pour dire que l'armagedon
permet qui a plus de parties plus de
parties qui t des autres chances que ça
revienne et plus d'Armon plus aarmagadon
en
fait le truc suto
entretient après les gens pensent qu'on
est contôle quand on diton que ça plus
longtemps mais c'est juste ça nous ça
nous rapporte plus d'argent en fait en
soi oui en soi donc en fait nous on veut
que ça dure plus longtemps c'est plus ça
dure mieux c'est mieux c'est les gens
pensent qu'on
estth second degré al est premer degré
en fait on veut juste prendre la
caillasse
bon des fois si ça
s'arrêtait on fera autre chose ça serait
sympa aussi hein mais ah ça serait quand
même dommage fa bon on passe à côté
quand même que ça dure jusqu'au bout de
la
nuit et en gros là tu vois le le ce
qu'ils nous font comme comme format
c'est un peu comme à la Coupe du monde
si tu joues ta première ronde tu fais
nul pas
farmagedon bon il y a un vainqueur
lendemain round 2 sil y a nul
Armagedon alors que bon d'accord alors
que peut-être tu as perdu la ronde 1 et
la ronde 2 tu fais nul mainant tu es
sorti tu as quand même un armagéon pour
peut-être quand même égaliser et avoir
quand même ta troisème manche avec un
autre armagadon alors moi je suis désolé
d'un truc c'est que quoi qu'il en soit
je préfère le mort surite à l'armagadon
genre par exemple moi personnellement et
c'est un truc qui dure encore plus
longtemps ah mais mais je préfère
réellement c'est admettons que tu
vraiment avoir un gagnant dans le 7 vous
rejouez tu rejoues deux parties en 5 + 2
les mecs font nul tu rejoues deux
parties en 3 + 2 et s'il continuent à
faire nul tu fais mort subite une par
une par une et une par une et mort
subite là ça ressemble plus à un tie
break au tennis pour moi e mais là tu
voas quand même tu casses quelque chose
tu casses la
cadence 15 minutes justement tu ouais
bah oui mais comme ils ont fait nul en
15 minutes tu veux les départager on qu'
étaient au même niveau aujourd'hui en 15
minutes et faut bien trouver quelque
chose mais je trouve en plus que c'est
plus juste
sportivement en fait moi j'aime pour moi
c'est un dernier c'est vraiment le
dernier recours quoi c'est quand tu as
tout fait parce qu'ils ont plus la bonne
cadence tu peux jouer pour faire nul ça
tellement le jeu Star
magadon
très
énervé du coup il t B4 c'est ça il est
pas obligé de
faire3 je crois qu'
obligé je crois que malheureusement
qu'on ne pourra pas se délecter de
l'armad
ici qui g cette première manche va
passer sur l'autre match Magnus lui
arrive à
l'emporter
alors une faute
ah on va quand même j'espère qu'on va
avir
l'armadon bien se délecter quoi les Val
juste avant quand même pas facile mais
là c'est encore plus difficile c'est la
faiblesse de
fabianooui c'est parti où il mne au
score avec les blanc il sait pas s'il
doit jouer faire nul il
hésite trop ité il est pas
bien il dorait s'incliner Fabiano et
nous
offrir mais je je je je me rends compte
qu'au fur à mesure des tourins ce truc
de cadence qui régresse et de et de mort
subite ça ça perd de plus en plus en
popularité surtout quand tu as un 7 tu
pourrais dire oui mais euh du coup il y
en a un qui a les blanc en premier en
mort subite bon j'ai envie de te dire
bon c'est le bol après hein tu peux
faire un pil ou face ou quoi ça joue aux
échecs mais là en plus il y a deux set
tu pour dire bah dans le premier set en
cas de machin tu auras les blancs et
puis dans le deuxème tu auras eu les
noir
enfin mais les gens aiment pas trop
système c'est est pas mal pourant en
plus dans la BUP ça vraiment bien marché
ça fait monter l' HPE au contraire quoi
tu sais que chaque partie décisive et
ouais puis quand lesc ça peut durer
ouais mais quand les nul s'enchaîn en
plus l'impression que l'importance du
truc c'est comme au tennis quoi il y a
le enfin je sais pas le T break 6 6 7 7
7 7 8 9 je sais pas des fois ça m'est
arrivé d'avir des ta break tuas 14 14 en
l'intensité elle monte quoi c'est
génial moi j'adore quoi en fait je
trouve le mort subite si si quand même
tu arrivriveras à 3 nul et puis bon de
toute façon tu fais 15 minutes de pause
donc à la rigueur tu auras le temps de
faire enfin là tu rejoues tu machins
tu bon je vais délivrer Michat ouais
délivre
Micha moi j'aime
bien pour être l'avocat du diable tu
peux pas départager un T rapide avec des
Blitz
ouais mais l'ARM Gon ça te dénature
encore
plus tu vois il te dit que tu peux pas
départager du rapide avec du Blitz mais
ouais mais en ouais du monde il font
comment un match championnat du monde
mais il dé partage des longues avec des
rapides et puis avec des blit si jamais
enfin moment tu es si tu es si si tu
dois en fait
ouais mais après il disait je fais
l'avocat
diable donc diabed et oui c'est le c'est
l'argument de c'est l'argument de
l'avocat du diable c'est c que je te
disais aussi tu casses la cadence mais
mais qu'en fait oui bon ben vaut mieux
quand
même oh
mais ils ont plus 15 minutes en est
moins sûr qu' jou les bon coup quand
même mais je trouve que tu casses moins
le jeu que l'armagadon en fait ouais
comparativement mais là j'ai
l'impression que c'est un tournoi
d'armagedon hein je te le dis comme ça
c'est ça tout le temps chaque
[Musique]
ronde il y a 90 % de matchs qui seagedon
quoi
c'est mais c'est étonnant parce que là
par exemple Fabiano il doit jamais se
faire égaliser je sais pas pourqu ils
font égalisés comme ça pourquoi ils
savent pas faire les matchs le tournoi
est bizarre
il va prendre le pion il prend des deux
et dame
D6 va être bien pourri avec une tour
active sur la zone ranger unon de plus
et tour et tourfou contre tour
cavalier
va pouvoir s'en
vouloir rond il doit pas perdre quoi
complètement
gagnant plus 7
rappelons
B4
ouais c'est sy pas ça va pas faire longu
cette
[Musique]
finale il a raison de la jouer oui bon
ça Bange pas de pain si réussi à chasser
la tour de la deuxème tuas une petite
chance je P réussi à avoir F7 k C4 tour
2 ro
F1 du coup sur K4 tu dois partir tu mets
ta tour en C2 h tu te bats gen tu es
perdant
mais B sur SK C4 tu vas faire tour D4 je
fais tour C2 h je va te refaire des fous
aussi j'is
B3 commence par B3 regarder son cavalier
mais
bon fait cavalier à 3 et tour de T
C2 mais bon il ch
tour
il peut-être qu'
b5i C7 peut-être ici ici ou mais bon
c'est le
coup ser la tuile allez petite tuile
tu es pour une tuile ouais
bon
après tu penses que Magnus il gagne ça
contre l'ordi ou
pas je sais pas bonne question en fait
bon plutôt oui
mais il fallait qu'il sait Ding que la
GAE soit si pessimiste bah en fait ce
que la Jae elle trouve instante
elle trouve en force comment simplifier
la position euh avant de manière
avantageuse elle fait quoi elle fait
tour des de la jauge elle fait même même
pas qu'il a B5 elle faisait
elle faisait
F4
bien il a pas du tout aimé fa
quoi il fait la fait on sait pas trop la
jauge il a du mal à être bien
réactif assez nul en fait
oui il est complètement claqué au sol la
bon il fait ce qu'il peut pour essayer
de pas perdre sur le champ mais bon ça
se passe mag avance sa majorité il a un
fou qui joue sur les deux a et
cet il ve faire F5 je ce fou F6
peut-être
après je trouve qu' je hyper bien quand
même nous oui on aosé une grande
résistance il peut
pas F5 t
H4 tourner
je crois qu' coup qui sont joués mais
qui arrivent pas là non je crois qu' B4
C3 je sais pas je crois que a bugé
terrible cette technologie DGT qui est
pas pas au
point malheureusement c'est pour ça que
les blit tu peux vraiment pas suivre
rapide ça va mais en blitz ça arrive
trop
souvent
c'est étonnant qu' arrivent pas à mettre
un système
de je sais pas que chaque pièce soit
identifiée qu' une caméra qui
te que ce soit facile quoi pas que ce
soit juste des déjà c'est bizarre que
quand tu bouges la pièce il la suiv en
fait normalement enfin moi quand j'ai
voulu faire une techno comme ça ce qu'
proposé le gars quand on avit réfléchi
c'est qu'en fait à chaque fois que tu
appuies sur la pendule l'ordinateur il
fasse un scan la position son les trucs
ou ce soit que quand tu appuies sur la
pendule mais c'est pas con que des fois
tu tu vas en 4 je recule
ou du coup si un bug il rentre dans un
autre mode où il il cl scan mais euh
mais que de base ils sont en scan que
quand la pendu appuyé mais là oui on a
pas les coups quoi en fait juste on peut
pas voir la partie donc on ne sait pas
pour ça que la backup se joue sur
ordinateur si les gens me
demandent
il défend vraiment bien
Fabiano ah il manque beaucoup de coup
quoi
Magnus avance le roi sur sur la caméra
faire G6 F5 s'installer le fou
durablement c'est dommage qu' VO pas la
suite parce que c'est qume palpitant de
savoir si on aura un ou pas du coup on
ne sait pas on pense que oui on espère
que oui mais on est en doute trop au
doute et tu vois quand on en parlait
plutôt que ça je disais que Fabiano Mo
pour avoir vu tous les temp fait de gros
de gros progrès en
rapide je parler en
connaisseur connaissance de cause genre
actuellement il est vraiment genre top 3
4 mondial en
rapide par qu' nétait pas avant ça voil
la contre magn a plus une t un tel écart
de niveau en fait entre les deux il est
en train de suer j'ai l'imession mais
bon je sais
pas il a sué bon ben il a perdu on voit
pas les coups mais il a perdu voilà donc
il aura il y aura un armeageddon et puis
et puis voilà je sais pas quoi
dire voilà tous les coups sont arrivés
d'un coup ça c'est la positionion
finale bon cétait perdant depuis
longtemps et puis
ça Magnus avec sa technique qui ul qui a
qui a fait exploser son adversaire de
partout et ben on va attendre les
enchères tout ça et et puis on va se
délecter je sais pas peut-être dans une
10 15 vingtaine trentaine de minutes
quoi là on voit Magnus qui est en train
de noter qui doit bien réfléchir à ce
qui l'enchère qu' va donner s veut les
blancs les noirs et pas se tromper à
quelques secondes près peut-être qui
seront capital pour la suite de ce
match answer you don't see it how about
now manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from Chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolf magnet kit
and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
chess at
[Musique]
displate.com
et on est reparti mesames et Messieurs
avec donc Fabiano Caron avec les pièces
blanches obligé de l'emporter dans cette
Armageddon Magnus avec les pièces noires
qui a 8 minutes
50 quand même une Sicilienne ouais avec
que 6 cette fois il a pas laess en
canen can je
crois Fabi qui connait bien quand même
ça réto que4 ouis c'est un truc agressif
avec les Noirs alors qu'il joue pour nul
ouais
mais mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
qu'ils aiment pas trop subir en fait oui
mais c'est avec les blancs ils subissent
h avec les Noirs normal ou f G4 ou F4
voilà c'est bien ça va de l'avant tout
ça
on dit qu'on va voir unich sur le truc
sur le stream comme quoi des fois les
pubs ça marche bah c'est les échecs avec
des avec des
sorts des S ah ou le fameux
ou c'est vraiment
magnifique d'un coup tu
as SC pour qu'ou ouais voilà c'est ça tu
as tout un tas de sorts et monter vers
ici ou je ne sais quoi enfin là je monre
des trucs mais oui j'imagine qu'ils vont
pas d' coup une pièce peut bouger comme
un cavalier ENF tuas tu as des sorts tu
peux utiliser toi très très puissant qu
ouais mais tu as des points de mana donc
j'utilis la bontion au bon moment les
recharger
peut-être non mais c'est très beau jeu
c'est hyper
compliqué enfin faut bien calculer du
coup c'est netement plus dur que les
échecs bah c'est les échecs mais nêement
plus complexes mais c'est B jeu après on
soit juste faut avoir la force de
calcul il faut cliquer Fabi réfléchis
pendant H4
c'est H4 H5
hein pourqu il fait pas F4 je sa pas
issu il fait de l'autre côté il voulait
pas voir B5 en tout cas bon peut faire
B6 s'il a
envie moi j'ar plutôt avec A3 ce truc
généralement h tu peux attendre B5 et
faire A3 ouais de toute façon s' fait a
5 ça prise en B5 il fait B4 tu le
bouffes ouais
parce que ça te permet plus de faire
petit grand rock si tu as envie que ce
pion a 4 qui a l'air un peu de te te
fermer même si bon c'est pas interdit
interdit
mais pourquoi ce temps pour Magnus de
mon parce que c'est l'armagadon
Laurent et donc il peut faire nul et
remporter le match mais il a moins de
temps en
échange
mais qui gagne c'est nul si nul et ben
ce ser noirs donc que
Carlsen c'est toute la beauté de cette
arm voilà ou tu gagnes en faisant nul
mais tu as moins de temps et tuas les
noir
en tout cas ça pousse côté Fabi il a son
pion H5 c'est bien bientôt prêt à faire
G6 intéressant parce que ça fracasse la
structure de pion des noir et notamment
aussi le pion E6 qui pourra devenir
faible alors pour l'instant attention la
torchin est pas défendu donc faudra
peut-être faire grand rock ou F2 ou je
ne sais quel coup mais bon sûrement
grand ro vrai dire euh pour pour ensuite
faire G6
t
C8 bah pourquoi pas grand quand même
j'ai envie de dire par que je suis en
train so quoi je suis en train d'chir
l'ordi dit quoi tour gant j'avais aussi
mais j'aurais fait grand R
perso il va pour t G1 en tout cas bon
l'idée c'est cl j'aurais pas joué ouis
puis tu t'enlèves aussi de de la diagale
oui bien sûr bien
sûr plus 620 pour Magnus he il y a pas
de rajout ça peut euh jusqu'au 60 avoir
son
importance bien évidemment peut-être il
va faire G6 lui-même voilà pour éviter
que l'adversaire ne le fasse c'est pour
ces raisonl que j'aime bien la tour Hin
mais il revient du coup ouais mais tu es
peut-être content d' provoquer G6 parce
que là tu as peut-être P on prend G6
intermédiaire alors là faut calculer
puis on prend G6 puis on prend4 prend
des4 mais tu voou tu prends H7 en BL
j'aurais fait ça ouais mais des fois ce
que tu aurais fait en blis tu le ferais
pas avec plus de
temps bah du coup il faut faut voir
quelque chose de faux mais une bonne
raison mais alors sur AG en fait je truc
pu on prend F donc c'est juste fini G
est fini ouais c'est sûr non mais LG FG
obligé oui mais du coup tu es content de
toute façon mais bon al il fait F5 ok
mais c'est pas c'est plutôt intuitif
hein tu atttaques la tour tu vas faire
F6
c'est pas
simple à juger ça ce qui ce qui est pas
facile FG cavalier
F3 mais du
coup si c'est pour ça 4 aussi du coup
truc normal la même position
normalevee truc
normal bon après a rien de fait enfin on
critique sans critiquer trop c'est juste
l'impression qu'il pas optimisé ce qu'il
pouvait avoir après ça reste très
compliqué comme position parce que aucun
roiqu le roment resté vers le centre
après il y a la paire de fou le7 qui
peir vers C5 vers5 il a des Atou avec
j'ai l'impression qu'il fait une erreur
qui qui continue un peu à faire en
rapide et en blitz c'est qu'il essaie
trop de jouer le plus fort c'est un truc
que m'avait dit Vlad m'a dit les mecs
sont très très bon en longue et un peu
Mo bon en
rapide c'est souvent parce queil
s'adapte pas
h genre parfois fa des trucs un peu plus
faciles à jouer quoi ouais qui sont
peut-être même pas moins bons en plus
hein ouii mais moins principal quoi bah
là il se trouent qu' 4 en plus c'était
pas bon donc mais il faut éviter les
trucs disons quand tuésites entre deux
et que ça a l'air équivalent un truc
fait normal ouais
normal il m'a dit souvent les joueurs
qui sont moins bons en rapide c'est que
ils ont tendance à avoir un compliquer
la vie avoir le mauvais réflexe quand
ils ont peu de
temps Têtre fpran et damage
2 j' fait j'aurais essayé de caler un
grand rock en fait moi j'étais dans un
délire je calculé fou pr pis on prend
grand rock fou B4 3 bien prend C3 tour
C1
h il a peut-être dame F7 ou E7
ouais mais bon
les grand ro direct tu
peux mais bon du coup tu ça pas
ou avec le pion A3 tu c'est tout tout
serait mieux quoi contesens il fait F 3
peut-être contesens aussi ou pas on
verra il veut peut-être venir vers D4
ou il peut s'en vouloir qu' lui-même
hein petit toute façon attaque le
cavalier F3 cavalier F3 il a joue un peu
vite quand même
ouais problème c'est qu' 5 pu 5 dans mat
de fou B4 ouais qu'est-ceil va jouer des
tel non mais il va faire qu' des 4 là
ouais
ok des qu
Fabi bah il avait il avait la position
sympa après l'ouverture et
puis voilà il a fait comme prévu et donc
d dame
D7 faire et B4 il peut faire5 peut-être
encore non mais va battre enfin me
semble pas fait tout ça juste bon il
doit être objectivement moins bien car
en jouant assez vite même bien bien
subit de choc de l'ouverture et euh bon
voilà tu prends une fois ou pas
ou non en B5 en B5
ouais non bah là non on s'ans calculer
trop juste en regardant comme
ça moi j'aurais
pris mais VO bien un B4 qui est D5 tu ma
damage de
encore pire il a toujours
H5
j'ai en fait ouais moi j'aurais fait ça
aussi ouis je veux bien croire juste
j'avais pas envie de voir la Colona quoi
P je per à 4 je per à 4 et puis puis
voilà quoi par qu'en fait sur B4 je
vouis faire D5 moi je fa5 aussi
mais jeis bouou d'
4 j'aijà B3 éviter j'ai T8 à
éviter c'est trop pour moi quoi mais
damage surour
F7 passe complètement à côté Fabi mais
c'est parti de A4
oui D5 plutôt bien joué pète le centre
le fou 7 va arriver en D5 ou la dame et
le fou E7 revit défend son P en B4
j'aime bien ce que fait l'ordi tour H7
damage 2 pour bouffer au moins le
cavalier un peu [__] le
bordel tu peut-être même caler tour h
avant c'est mat
ouais mais je prend je pense c vraiment
ta
chance
çaement mais tu vois faire tour H7 ça
damage de ça tour H1 menace mat F D6 dam
H8 3
F7 t F1
enfin bon tu vas perdre mais tuas fait
un donneur fait un bar ouais et tu peux
pas forcément tout calculer de base pere
il va mal déessiner un truc en plus tu
encore du K 6 peut-être j'en sais rien
moi
mais non parce qu'on a pas de menace non
mais gen tu vas finir par perdre mais de
loin là tu vas pas voir tout ça ouais
non ouais c'est ça mais genre qui à
tenté quelque chose t'envoie quoi ça ou
cavalier F5 son autre
coup puis on prend G6
c'est bien NAS quand F6
ouais non mais non mais
ision tu perds pas comme un agneau
mais il a fait quoi il a rien fait pour
l'instant
issu mais il fait deux parties horribles
avec les Blancs oui d'affilé coup sur
coup là son à 4 était vraiment
cata
meilleur coup
ouais en fait mauvais mais bon mauvais
comme tu veux enfin rien ne va quoi le
mal est déjà
fait on veut pas perdre comme un agneau
quoi
terrible cette armagadon pas une belle
partie Fabi a trop mal
joué il est Mar car en fait qui dans la
Magon a joué le gain avec les
Noirs mais j'ai l'IM que des fois c'est
plus simple que juste de subir tu
prendre la pression la pendule et
défendre des trucs de merde
ouais non plus je sais pas Fabiano il
sait pas ouais tu cliques les coups
quoi voà Magnus va vraiment gagner le
premier 7 contre le cours du match h
première partie doit perdre mais il est
quand même mené au score il fait t
7 le truc c'est qu'il a pas assez clic
quoi il va faire fou 6 de toute façon
c'est le seul
coup F F4
OK
bon il a réussi à poser un problème
oui non Mo il prend une chance pratique
bon que ça va pas mais on sait jamais
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer surtout
dans ce tourno ou là il y a pas6 là si
mais préparé quelque chose dessus
ouais mais al il a complètement laissé
passer son
avantage qu'après damage 3 il va t
obligé de ah mais de
3 il a juste vu nul en
faitage 3 il va prendre F4 ouais c'est
bien joué la tour ou du Fou enfin de ce
qu' ve va faire B3 mais c'est quand on
dit que l'armadon n'ime pas trop c'est
un peu à cause de ça ça trop le jeu là
il tue la partie avec son bien joué en
fait bien joué ouais mais genre c'est
pas ça vraiment être un truc de dernier
recours c'est pas que c'est pas marrant
c'est qu' avir une fois temp tempsours
c'est cool mais là c'est tout le temps
ça
quoi
après c'est serait bien joué il est très
heureux c'est fini alors ah bah
complètement damage 3 c'est le seul
coup truc norm aussi c'était vraiment
une connerie he ouais mais bon tu faire
de toute façon il y a pas de
coup c'est pas la seule manière de
gagner dame G7 mais non mais il gagn en
deux quoi enfin mais il gagne très très
bien il gagne l'ARM Guedon il fait nul
la partie
mais bien joué Magnus il pris G7 du coup
bah oui il doit comme il peut pas faire
nul il se suicide
quoi mais il va voir qualité de moins ah
il
prend ça fera une torte
plus tu pas abandonné là
non tour c'est quand même beaucoup non
ouis c'est un peu beaucoup il d'avoir le
seum Fabi c'est beau que Magus
réfléchisse t je pense qu'il sait
conclure he
il sait ouis non mais il do pas
comprendre pourquoi il joue quoi mais
j'aurais fait t prend C3 ouais tu prends
C3 on prend le 4 faut prendre le
4 mais pourquoi il joue je sais
pas il sait plus pourquoi il joue il
arrêté euh écoute voilà Magnus il g donc
la première manche mais les deux joueurs
vont se retrouver demain déjà pour la
suite pitante demi-finale donc victoire
aujourd'hui d'Abd satf et Magnus scène
dans les deux premières manches merci à
tous à demain bonneir